l'animal avec les 0 1
je compte pas en augmentant la à je suis
président la république moi je suis à
paris mme tapé trop chaud cdd si je vais
y passer
fo jl il était bien il était frais rien
je t'ai connu plus drôle laurent
[Musique]
bah
alors
[Musique]
tél
chers amis chers ennemis bienvenue sur
le plateau de tout le monde en parle
l'émission où tout le monde parle avec
nous ce soir en un faux nom comme ça
pourquoi pourquoi d'ailleurs à couper
pourquoi t'as pas enchaîné parce que on
a dit qu'on faisait des répètes et tout
mais il y avait une sorte de grâce le
public était beau tout était bon fallait
y aller quoi tu vas leur faire des
tâches ils vont être moche mais on est
content
qu'est-ce qu'on fait frédéric bon ben on
va la garder un bon aller avec nous ce
soir
mona fabien galthié
armande aller
révélations sur la mort de mme ockrent
sophie thalmann
m
cindy lauper
la science sur bv
wozniak
londres
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir et merci bonsoir ça va
la vie pour toi en ce moment tu te
fatigue pas trop un thé chez toi
tranquille peinard
rien de spécial à faire en ce moment
c'est la période de repos
c'est marrant il en fallait tu te laisse
vivre en ce moment mais complètement la
web app ou là dans les émissions de télé
est rien du tout rien voyant la
pondération ballard est en préparation
pour te dire si je me sens concerné mais
tu vas reconnecter avec la france à
allah allah ça marche ça ça merci à nos
amis téléspectateurs sa recherche
et puis des cartes de bons clients
laurent des cartes de bons clients
bonjour taton berdot si des fois voilà
si une [__] qui me gave un peu ou un
blaireau qu'il ya un mot plus haut que
l'autre
et maintenant tu cites
soir
[Musique]
voici arlette laguiller et olivier
besancenot
voilà arlette laguiller et olivier
besancenot merci d'être la première
un plateau l'ensemble alors
notre bloc
bravo bravo pour cette union bon on y va
c'est la première fois que vous êtes sur
un plateau de télévision ensemble il
faut le dire à billets est habitué merci
d'avoir choisi tout le monde en parle on
en est très fier pour l'heureuse
nouvelle
alors cette différence d'âge ça pose pas
des problèmes
politique non et voilà donc la lcr et lo
sont d'accord pour présenter des listes
communes aux élections régionales et
robert également d'accord pour baisser
la clim vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
ça fait partie du programme
ça fait partie du programme mais d'un
bond à antonio il faut voilà évidemment
ça a l'air très beau comme ça on se dit
ça y est ils ont reçu une espèce
d'illumination du saint-esprit bien que
ce soit pas trop votre truc mais on dit
c'est formidable et puis on découvre
qu'en fait c'est cette union que l'on
croit d'amour est en fait un mariage de
raison c'est parce que la loi électorale
a changé et qu'en fait on n'est plus
dans le proportionnel mais dans le
scrutin majoritaire à deux tours et donc
je voulais être présent au deuxième tour
il faut vous mettre d'accord non je
crois que c'est un accord politique
c'est pas en accord électoralistes wen
s'est retrouvé nos deux organisations et
puis d'autres assez présent à s'est
rassemblée pour les mobilisations
sociales du printemps sur la question
des retraites notamment
et puis on est présents ensemble dans
nos nombreux combats sociaux dont on a
des divergences mais on a plus de points
communs que de différences pour cause et
découvrir ce même programme mais sur
beaucoup de choses évidemment puisqu'on
a manifesté caudroit vous avez attendu
que la loi change pour vous mettre
d'accord il ya longtemps que vous avez
un programme à savoir cette loi est fait
pour empêcher les petits partis
d'obtenir des élus la part à 10%
elle a été faite pour ça donc à partir
pas très démocratique ça dehors de la
loi n'est pas et antidémocratique
absolument et de ce point de vue là
effectivement peut-être les électeurs
nous aiderons t-il à franchir cette
barre des 10% pour être présent au
second tour
d'accord j'ai la photo officielle c'est
la faute que c'est la photo pour les
mairies voilà merci
donc olivier le 2 novembre la lcr a
donné son accord à des listes communes
non sans mal parce qu'il y avait
certains militants qui avaient rejoint
la lcr après le 21 avril et qui
comprennent mal l'association de la lcr
avec hello d'arlette laguiller qui a
quand même refusé d'appeler à voter
chirac le au deuxième tour il ya eu des
dissensions et des débats dans notre
organisation on a eu une discussion
démocratique à tous nos militants qui
sont prononcés entre autres sur cet
accord à l'occasion notre congrès et il
ya effectivement 30% de nos militants
qui sont prenez se prononcer contre cet
accord là mais là dedans y'a pas que des
nouveaux militants enfin si je dirais
c'est un vieux débat entre nous parce
que parce que c'est une question qui se
pose effectivement régulièrement
je crois aussi bien à l'occasion des
élections qu'à l'occasion des luttes et
c'est pour ça que c'est important de
comprendre qu'il ya quand même quelque
chose qui se passe entre arlette et moi
entre lutte ouvrière et la lcr c'est
aussi des rapports militants constante
c'est pas seulement un combat fronting
comme claudia schiffer et david
copperfield n'ont pas tout à fait c'est
pareil c'est pas l'île de la tentation
ne faisait pas ça essayer de faire
entendre une voix en service le message
access
on est très efficace et bien sincèrement
votre histoire et son jeu on est plus
forts dès qu'ils sont deux des fils un
crime est coupée à peu près les rapports
de force incroyable
alors imaginons la queue dans ces
élections qui se préparent à un moment
le front national soit en passe de
gagner
est ce que vous faites vous appeler à
voter contre lui quand même on a décidé
que effectivement là où le front
national serait en passe de gagner une
région on appellerait à voter pour la
gauche pas pour la droite alors lutte
ouvrière n'a pas encore pris cette
décision c'est le 6 et 7 décembre c'est
votre congrès ça peut être rejetée
non non non on s'en fait plus que sa
main non non ça va être malade et j'ai
halluciné dans la préparation de notre
congrès
bien sûr qu'il ya des réticences pour
les raisons opposées sur la différence
d'âge quand même joue pas pour les
raisons opposées à celles de la lcr mais
je pense qu'on aura une large majorité à
notre congrès je sait pas encore de
combien
c'est le congrès alors moins soixante
dix la ba oui j'espère moi 70 pour se
présenter ensemble
qu'est ce que vous avez déjà couché
ensemble non je gardais mais laissez le
nom est ce que vous avez déjà couché
ensemble vos idées sur le papier c'est à
dire vous avez déjà un protocole
d'accord il ya une profession de foi
commune pour les élections dites moi a
qu à cause d'arlette comme la lcr
s'écarte un peu plus de la grande
famille de gauche parce qu'avant il y
avait quand même des passerelles entre
la lcr la gauche socialiste y avait
beaucoup de gens des lacs sont passés au
ps
est ce que finalement vous n'êtes pas en
train de vous faire comme ça je veux
récupérer par lutte ouvrière
séduit par arlette laguiller mais de
toute façon elle serait pas très âgée
c'est de toute façon je crois que à
gauche c'est une vraie rupture que ça se
court pour lutte ouvrière ou la lcr
vis-à-vis tout l'ex gauche plurielle qui
continue à maintenir le même cap c'est à
dire qu'ils continuent à nous faire
croire qu'on pourrait accompagner plus
ou moins socialement le libéralisme
moi j'ai jamais eu de passerelles par
connivence quelconque avec un
strauss-kahn - fa bus qui passent par
exemple privatiser la poste a et le vélo
oui qu'est ce qui va devenir le vélo le
vélo de jg il va être privatisée lever
le pied il faudrait en parler parce que
de bureaux de poste sur 6000 bureaux de
poste qui qui vont qui vont être
supprimés la cour des comptes qui se
transforme en espèces de conseillers
financiers patronat a expliqué texto que
le réseau distribution était
surdimensionné donc j'ai traduit pour
que ça soit simple ça veut dire qu'il va
y avoir des bureaux de poste qui vont
sauter en pagaille dans les quartiers
populaires et dans les zones rurales
parce qu'ils sont plus rentables et
concrètement ces 6000 bureaux qu'il
s'agit de faire disparaître l adéquat
sur leurs ennemis
tp j'avais envie de dire cette phrase
fait remettre la caisse
oui tu as raison ça booste les neurones
à on retrouve tous très sympathiques
arrêté et olivier mais quand on commence
à parler de votre programme des fois ça
fait un peu froid dans le dos on va
prendre un certain nombre de points
vous allez me dire si c'est ça ou si
c'est pas ça par exemple interdiction
des licenciements dans les entreprises
en particulier les entreprises qui font
des profits et celles qui font pas le
profil bas celles qui font pas trop fils
et sous réserve d'inventaire
où est passé l'argent donc ça veut dire
eh oui ça veut dire control contrôle des
comptes en banque contrôle de des
travailleur social parce que tout sur
les violences je dis ça parce que la
chose soit fait froid dans le dos en
date et olivier sont géniaux sauf qu'il
faut savoir que si vous êtes au pouvoir
vous viendrez il y aura quad et qui va
venir vérifier les comptes des
entreprises si les travailleurs avaient
accès au compte de leur propre
entreprise serait déjà pas mal et je
crois qu'on pourrait démontrer que les
licenciements ne sont pas justifiées et
que bien souvent on licencie simplement
pour augmenter les dividendes des
actionnaires et il n'y a aucune raison
il n'y a aucune raison que ça soit
toujours les travailleurs qu'ils fassent
les frais d' c'était comique où tout est
basé on va sur le premier league donc
interdiction des licenciements oui
surtout dans les entreprises qui font
des bénéfices et même dans celles qui
n'en feraient pas si des fois l'argent
était un petit peu consacré à acheter
dans le train des manteaux de fourrure à
la femme du patron voilà ont beaucoup
d'entreprises qu'en disent qu'elles vont
supprimer des emplois
parce qu'elles vont mal appartiennent à
des grands groupes est en réalité font
des produits donc tout ça il faudrait
pouvoir le coup alors ensuite création
de centaines de milliers d'emplois dans
l'administration et les services publics
oui bah oui au contraire un pays où tout
le monde et quatre autres fonctionnaires
quand même oui mais attendez
ceux qui disent ça ils n'ont pas besoin
de se faire soigner à l'hôpital
ils savent pas qu'on manque
d'infirmières bordant dans l'école
donc on pourrait créer des centaines de
milliers de fonctionnaires en plus bas
par exemple dans la santé ça peut être
tout de suite maintenant passons 20120
parce que les syndicats comme ça mais
oui mais honnêtement si l'auteur de la
canicule je m'excuse mais la canicule
serait qu'on ne pouvait pas le prévoir
ma force de fermer des lits d'hôpitaux
et de refuser d'embaucher depuis des
années des années ce gouvernement comme
le précédent bas effectivement s'avérer
mais même sans la canicule la nuit dans
les hôpitaux il ya deux infirmières pour
quatre étages en continu rouge de
salaire alors vous allez augmenter les
salaires
nous on est pour lire que les salaires
demande même dans l'audiovisuel
même dans l'audiovisuel je sais pas si
passionnant hormis peut-être sagement
dans vous pensez sérieusement c'est très
important
vous pensez que le salaire minimum en
france devait être de combien admettons
le minimum que quelqu'un gagne
écoutez le minimum c'est ses 1500 euros
quand même c'est par jour mais oui bien
sûr
vous n'êtes pas un maximum non j'imagine
oui 1600 euros c'est bien sincèrement
quand on voit le peu d'augmentation de
salaire pour dire pas du tout d'ailleurs
pour les fonctionnaires 0 en 2003 05
début 2015 quand on voit à côté de ça
effectivement toute hâte à 2 2 p dg qui
ont des salaires énormes stocks comme
moi aussi il y aurait besoin de la
forcer à combien imaginons c'est très
bien olivier comme moi que ça ça sera
l'objet de luttes et qu' il faudra
effectivement se bagarrer pour obtenir
ça et on verra bien dans le le décours
de la lutte ce que décideront les
travailleurs ce qui revêt les
travailleuses notre programme
salvadorienne et pas des caillons pour
le prochain programme électoral le sien
c'est pas d'écrire pour le prochain
programme électoral les fiches de paye
de chacun et de chacune
simplement c'est de réduire au maximum
il établir l'égalité va serrer
l'éventail des salaires j'imagine comme
resserré hier l'un d'eux quoi parce
qu'aujourd'hui 80% de la population qui
vit avec 1200 euros par mois et le pdg
de l'oréal il va gagner en une seule
minute parce que j'avais vraiment rien
ne pourra pas gagner toute sa vie donc
c'est écoeurant
ouais donc cela la répartition des
richesses il faut la faire
alors on va regarder un petit peu
rapidement comme ça c'est pdg de l'oréal
pour dire qu'ils gagnent beaucoup plus
si vous étiez au pouvoir tous les deux
images inom qui dirigerait le pays il y
aura un président un public où il y aura
un comité 1 aurait des comités dans les
entreprises des comités de quartier ont
hérité de virages et le pouvoir central
commun il y aura un pouvoir sans qu'ils
seront bien sûr ça je sais pas parce
qu'il peut être à paris il peut être à
lille il peut être n'importe où et
combien de partis politiques duceppe
pour le pluralisme quand même tous les
partis politiques pour être autorisée il
aurait pas de financement des grandes
entreprises
voilà ça serait peut-être que les
leaders des partis devraient peut-être
aller distribuer des tracts à la porte
des hommes de fresnes où le front
national sera autorisée
je sais je crois pas que le front
national ce soit un problème
d'interdiction a je crois que de toute
façon si le front national était
interdite il existerait d'une façon plus
clandestine peut-être plus dangereuses
dans les mesures concrètes aussi au
niveau démocratique on pourrait estimer
que non seulement les élus sont pas
amenés à faire je ne sais pas combien de
mandat au cours de leur vie c'est à dire
faire en sorte que la politique devienne
pas un métier vous êtes d'accord avec
sarkozy vous dites qu'au bout de sarkozy
veut virer chirac au bout de ces accords
la cie la nitro games mot pour mot la
question du salaire parce que si on veut
que la politique devienne pas un métier
précisément ben moi je vois pas pourquoi
pourquoi ce conte des mandats gagne plus
que ceux qui sont censés représenter
c'est à dire la majorité de la rencontre
avec combien d'heures par semaine pas
écoutés nous déjà 35 heures elle était
appliquée partout sans réduction de
salaire sans flexibilité sans
annualisation du temps de travail ça
serait déjà pas mal peut-être on
estimerait que pour que tout le monde
ait un emploi
faudrait peut-être travailler moins il
partagé et et le travail et l ensemble
des richesses le travail qu'il faudrait
pour tout le monde et en emplois voilà
c'est ça en fait
moi qui suis vieille militante et bien
quand je manifestais des années 60 68
ont réclamé les 30 heures 30 heure mais
réclamait alors est ce que ce serait à
chacun selon ses besoins
oui oui c'est le second gros besoins
comment il ferait alors bas j'avais j'ai
paniqué je crois pas que les besoins de
chacun je crois que chacun aspire à
avoir de quoi vivre à pouvoir profiter
de loisirs
maintenant le gars qui peut ou la fille
qui peut pas vivre sans avoir trois
voitures différentes par exemple la
maison dans des endroits différents
qu'est ce que j'ai dans le coeur tant
pis j'ai pas peur mais moi oui
tant pis pour eux ils seraient obligés
de 700 kg à quelqu'un du monde
déjà que tout le monde ait un logement
un logement correct ou a déjà je te vois
ce que dans ce pays le droit au logement
d'ailleurs dans toute l'europe le droit
au logement
il est même pas respect que justement le
droit au logement est ce que vous êtes
pour la réouverture des maisons closes
non par ce biais là parce que sur la
question du logement il ya une autre loi
une vraie loi celle là elle existe c'est
pas celle des maisons closes c'est celle
de la réquisition des logements vides et
cette fois là elle est toujours pas
appliquée parce qu'il ya eu aucun
gouvernement qui a eu pour appliquer la
loi le courage de s'embrouiller ne
serait ce qu'un tout petit peu avec les
spéculateurs immobiliers par exemple
donc quand on parle des besoins et ses
marchands de biens efforts beaucoup de
mal à faire c'est les besoins faut
essayer des sériés parce qu'il ya des
besoins sociaux qui sont fondamentaux
élémentaire se loger se nourrir se
soigner
est ce que finalement
chirac vous utilisent pas un petit peu
comme mitterrand utiliser le front
national c'est à dire que finalement
vous l'aidez chirac parce que vous
emmerder le ps donc il est peinard comme
mitterrand tant que le fn emmerder la
droite il était peinard est-ce que c'est
pas un peu le même le même schéma je
sais pas si on emmerde le ps mais ce que
je sais si si si on fait beaucoup de
voix on va sacrément bt le patronat mais
ça me gonfle un peu cette histoire parce
qu'on l'entend depuis pas mal de temps
là l'histoire de les les pantins qui
sont un peu hein c'est à dire qu'il ya
la droite qui se met derrière alors la
droite quand même moi je me rappelle de
ce que disait gouvernement ce que disait
chirac le printemps dernier on n'était
pas en odeur de sainteté quand même
c'était la grande thème d'ailleurs c'est
complètement délirant c'était le thème
de la manipulation de l'extrême gauche
alors que c'est évidemment beaucoup plus
large que ça et puis je crois que de
toute façon nous notre objectif c'est de
construire une opposition crédible sur
des bases effectivement anticapitaliste
de défense des travailleurs à ce
gouvernement là parce que ce
gouvernement pour l'instant défend la
politique patronale
or après que ça emmerde le ps parce que
le ps au spa aujourd'hui ne serait ce
qu'au reprendre les revendications de la
rue c'est son problème mais qu'on nous
accuse pas à nous pas de claire par
rapport à cette question là nous on est
là pour se coltiner say yeah
alors les clés villiers et olivier
besancenot vous êtes les représentants
l'extrême gauche
vous ne serez pas étonné qu'on fasse une
interview où joue
[Musique]
alors j'ai voulu citer un certain mans 2
2 nom du ou semi politique et vous allez
me dire comme ça rapidement quelle
réaction vous avez sur eux sarkozy
arlette sarkozy je pense qu'il fait de
la démagogie sécuritaire démagogie
sécuritaire penser qu'il est président
ça j'en sais rien moi je voterai pas
pour lui c'est un siège
raffarin arlette raffarin bah écoute et
peut-être pas tirer sur les ambulances
j'ai l'impression que ça n'a pas très
bien pour lui que sa cote de popularité
est en baisse ses bienfaits du très
mauvais coup contre la classe ouvrière
elle si sévère et arlette oui c'est pas
cool pour lui va perdre son emploi tu
vas pas le défendre
non non mais il a en poitou laboy doit
avoir de quoi se reconvertir tu pense
qu'il ya un côté droit par arriviez
basse et la boîte de communication du
medef c'est à dire qui laissait paraître
il essaie de mettre en mots simples des
politiques qui vont nous faire très très
mal et de hausse en prenant la piale 22
moi j'irai en vigueur
bon bayrou olivier béraud j'ai vu ces
petites déclarations il fait on ne peut
plus dans le social en ce moment essayé
de faire oublier que sa politique c'est
libéralisme donc scellé privatisation de
services publics ça les fonds de pension
sur les retraites c'est la cdu
gouvernait blanc comme des lots fdf est
quand même dans le gouvernement
hélène ségara oh là là quoi pour hélène
ségara la suite à des revenus s'est elle
arrive à emporter ce ballon elle est
venue pour ça qu'elle est venue hélène
ségara oui vous l'aimez parti je n'en ai
d'ailleurs j'adore je vous dis
franchement qu'il aime
non non mais je suis sûr mais pourquoi
parce que j'ai pas trop le loisir de
d'écouté de la star ac toi tu est était
toujours bloquée nettement rumeurs pas
quand tu zappes tes poteaux pour qui toi
tu zappes quand même tu vois bien aimé
compter licenciement elle t'a dit oui
mais voilà on continue olivier carmarks
bas karl marx et il était là la semaine
dernière d'ailleurs il ya un mot pour
lui bah pour moi c'est évidemment à un
grand personnage dans l'histoire cac a
permis à un moment donné à la majorité
de la population de se dire on peut
avoir un projet d'émancipation on peut
avoir un projet de société alternatif et
puis évidemment je peux pas m'empêcher
de penser qu'on a dit tout et n'importe
quoi sur lui et que sa pensée a été
utilisé dans une dictature sanglante au
cours du siècle dernier qui était la
dictature stalinienne mais qui a rien à
voir pour moi avec le marxisme c'est
l'idée de l'égalité sociale et la
démocratie totale et sans limites pour
moi on est d'accord
castro c'est vrai que castro comme
beaucoup de leaders nationalistes comme
mao ou apporter des choses à leur peuple
la santé l'éducation dit oui il ya
beaucoup de gens là sont dites
ouvrir la santé l'éducation et que et
que cuba a pas grand chose à voir avec
un certain nombre de pays pauvres de ce
point de vue là même quand c'est sûr on
va bien sûr j'ai quand même mais bien
sûr je suis pas d'accord évidemment avec
le manque de liberté politique
il a du sang sur les mains il ya à cuba
oui oui certainement du sens en tout cas
il ay la fed et il a du sang pendant la
révolution mais enfin les américains
n'avaient encore plus
non mais aujourd'hui ils ont déjà
aujourd'hui encore max est inadmissible
que pour simplement exprimer exprimer
son opposition des gens soient en taule
pour 20 ans ou 22 d'accord là dessus on
est du côté des tubes en alors combat
général veut dire que un socialisme à
visage humain ça peut peut-être existé
donc moi c'est plutôt che guevara castro
voilà là je te mets à 8 parce que tu as
bien parlé george bush en vitesse
c'est un règne internationale au service
de la world company c'est vrai que ça
résume assez bien à ce qu'il est en
train de faire c'est quand même un
criminel pour le peuple irakien
même si
sam bien sûr ne regrette saddam hussein
mais c'est aux irakiens de diriger leur
pays
orlando vous connaissez orlando c'est un
chanteur ils exigent des clips et là il
ya tout sur la table si c'est quand il
est venu aussi bien continue ben laden
bras ben laden pour moi
cc
c'est aussi un criminel bien sûr un
jugement il ya moins d'un petit moment
c'est bon parce que les gens ont peur
maintenant
bon on attribue un peu facilement
maintenant tout se passe on va en parler
tout à la poste c'est vrai mais je pense
pas que ce soit quelqu'un qui soit pour
la libération des peuples même pas des
peuples musulmans évidemment olivier
michel drucker bas un présentateur de
télé j'ai mon nom vous et vous allez
fabriquer un dimanche après midi
c'est pourquoi sa conférence à charlieu
adinolfi drones et cela je connais plus
rafa bus
il fait de la moto il ya les mélange des
carottes râpées ou leurs jeunes il
essaye de faire ce revers jeunes je
crois que c'est quand même toujours les
vieilles idées gouvernementales et que
fabius il sera du côté du patronat pas
du côté des travailleurs non je crois
que dominique strauss kahn pareil pareil
pour vous ne lâchez pas s'il essaye de
faire jane lui mais pareil ils font
partie de ceux dans le parti socialiste
qui ont poussé à ce que le parti
socialiste tape à bras raccourcis à la
rentrée politique sur la gauche anti
capitaliste plutôt que de s'attaquer au
patronat par exemple parce que sur le
fond il pense vraiment qu à gauche le
choix c'est ça assez square où on pense
que finalement les mutations
industrielles en cours on les accompagne
et puis on n'a pas le choix on va mettre
une pincée de social surtout ça soit il
ya une rupture plus radicale et dans ces
cas là c'est l'été olivier eux ils ont
envie que le choix politique se pose
comme ça et du coup évidemment nous on
est en désaccord avec eux ce qui devait
s'arranger à ce qu'ils disent comme
sérieusement et u10 pour faire changer
les choses il faut être aux affaires
tant qu'on n'est pas aux affaires très
simple raconter ce qu'on va enfin
changer ce qu'ils disent c'est très bien
ça se fait qu'ils ont perdu que la
gauche plurielle a perdu 2,4 millions de
droits y compris parce que cela va
changer les choses quand il était
oui cinq ans pour le faire et par
exemple quand balladur a mis les
cotisations retraite dans le privé de 37
ans et demi à 40 ans psk eu cinq ans le
pouvoir il n'a pas changé les choses à
faire revenir sur ce qu'elle ait fait
balladur et même maintenant ils
s'engagent pas à défaire ce que raffarin
a fait donc la confiance ma voix n'a pas
coupé inconsciente bien on continue
mona ue alors j'ai franchement j'aime
l'indre et de chez blindés je peux te
racheter toi ton copain tellement comme
ça
[Musique]
on a bon soir heureusement vous voulez
pour bâle et du sida en afrique parce
qu'ils auraient fait la peau hâlée
j'attends et crever un temps attendue
donc on est c'est vrai quand même une
année où vous êtes d'accord vous
incarnez quand même la milliardaire
cosmopolite vous possédez 15 100 robes
de haute couture comment osez-vous mais
c'est surtout pour encourager cet arrêt
et des ah ok à ce qui continue parce
qu'ils vont préserver l'emploi dans la
haute couture que vous achetez des robes
alors
je l'aimé même pourquoi tu achètes
jamais de mcdo tu t'en fous des salariés
jeunes agresseurs mais c'est muna a
racheté le bateau de tapis qu'elle loue
à des gens elle loue tapie a déjà levé
tôt elle loue le bateau de tapis à des
gens pour un million deux par semaine
c'est ça je ne sais plus en france
propre
onovo a dit en europe 270 217 millions 4
le loup est facilement très facile aux
manettes
j'apporte de l'eau à votre moulin à
l'année ça fait combien ça laurent toi
qui compte bien en euros à la semaine 52
x 1 millions de bombes à ça fait
beaucoup d'argent en tirer ouais alors
bon on fait beaucoup dans le mécénat me
fait beaucoup dans la charité c'est tout
à fait vrai tout à fait sérieux richard
était bien mort 2e partie jusqu'à fériés
je vous ai jusqu'à soutenir les listes
et lo lcr aux prochaines élections
régionales
européenne au printemps 2004 mais une
fois que je comprends exactement quels
sont les objectifs 4 la charité c'est
pareil que vous y avez vous essayé de
mélanger charité la justice injuste pour
la légalité pour l'égalité pour
l'égalité la justice la liberté
l'indépendance oui madame faites gaffe
parce que tout le monde aime beaucoup
arlette et et olivier mais s'ils sont au
pouvoir ça va être dur fait gaffe 1 pour
vous les robes eelv on voulait prendre
le le faux c'est la faulx c'est à ça
c'est sûr qu'on va il aimait ça je m'en
fous là le fossé ac va devenir une
maison de retraite pour les salariés de
la poste du val de marne avant pourquoi
pas et pourquoi pas il ya plein de
château qu'on terminons la sécurité
sociale ont terminé pour faire y compris
des fêtes révolutionnaires
voilà dans la vraie question arlette
c'est ce que le partage doit être
autoritaire ou est-ce qu'il doit être
basée sur le bon vouloir des gens en
fait c'est ça l'histoire ce qu'elle
donne beaucoup mena moi j'ai le temps
d'une soirée
acheter une ampoule comme ça cent mille
francs elle peut le faire
enfin ces cent mille balles qui vont
pour les pour les africaines atteints du
sida donc les très généreuses mina may
vous ce que vous proposez c'est un
partage autoritaire s'est dit
reconnaissant ni le froid nous on lui
prendrait nous ce qu'on propose pour le
sida sait déjà qu'on que les grands
trusts pharmaceutiques donne à ceux qui
peuvent pas payer en afrique enfin vous
le savez est bien sûr c'est absolument
une catastrophe aujourd'hui l'afrique
est en train de se vider de ses
habitants à cause du sida
enfin des millions de femmes d'hommes
d'enfants qui meurent aujourd'hui du
sida et qui peuvent pas se soigner parce
que ils ont pas de quoi tout simplement
acheter les trithérapies tous je suis
pas une spécialiste de se rassurer et
donc c'est ça nous qu'on veut changer
que ces trusts arrête pour faire des
profits d'empêcher les gens de se
soigner dans les pays pauvres mais c'est
carrément criminel parce que quand dans
le cadre de la mondialisation
aujourd'hui c'est pas simplement qu'on
donne pas les moyens c'est qu'en plus il
ya un brevet indécent qu'impose un
monopole sur la fabrication de ces
médicaments et qui fait qu'effectivement
80% des malades ou pas accès à des
médicaments qui permettrait de traiter
la maladie ça si c'est pas récurrent
chez moi ce que c'est
alors tout à fait alors moon a donc 6 en
poule qu'on voit là sont des ampoules
appelé ithemba ce que dira espoir elles
sont décorées par des femmes
séropositives dans l'été en chine du cap
ce qui leur permet d'avoir des revenus
fixes au départ c'est une idée de civils
varet et cette année il a demandé à 30
styliste de mode ou couturier de
dessiner des ampoules voilà donc les les
prototypes les dessins originaux ont été
vendus aux enchères c'est là vous allez
acheter une est ensuite les séries
seront vendus dans les magasins en
profitent ces femmes africaines c'est ça
oui d'ensemble boutiques et magasins
aussi en europe
on espère les étendre aux etats-unis
l'année prochaine merci mona bras vous
un truc
est-ce que grâce à ça grâce à vos yeux
vous avez vu confisquer son bateau tout
de suite ou non non non écouter
moi je sais pas madame comment elle a
son argent si elle exploite des milliers
de travailleurs qu'elle licencie qu à
tout ça je sais pas si c'est ça j'ai
alors c'est eux qui me quittes
voilà ce qu'est ce qui vous quittent cet
autre chose donc je veux pas discuter de
ça se fait particulier bon elle fait
partie des riches qui se donne un peu
moins ont l'air préoccupé je connais
comme sans frontières moulin clown sans
frontières oui ça je te laisse
l'intitulé ce qui va faire un chèque d
avis et c'était très bien et bon dans
les pays en guerre pour porter des
spectacles aux enfants qui sont très
bien de réfugiés comme c'est peut-être
qu'une ce serait bien qu'ils fassent un
chez costa
merci mona mais il vous reste un peu
d'argent
non sérieusement je commence à
m'inquiéter moi voyez dès que je donne
in some j'ai un client plus vous voyez
dans la vie faut donner pour recevoir
tu vas recevoir mon nom est tu vas
recevoir bien alors moon aliou bah oui
vous êtes riche donc on va vous faire
une interview à si j'étais pauvre
[Musique]
alors mouna si vous étiez pour est ce
que vous auriez une montre comme ça
d'abord magnifique votre monde a fait
voir d'ailleurs caché là oui ça va
énerver a relaté olivier franchement
y'en a pour elle une problème tout se
passait bien jusqu'à vous rendez compte
je vais acheter l'extrême gauche à trois
ans de salaire ça à 30 ans khairy c'est
dur ça vaut quoi trois ans de salaire 4
ans de salaire non versé 6900 ça dépend
des prières aux pays bas
tu veux l'hiver que l'été les ppte et
bien donc si vous étiez pour vous auriez
demande comme ça quand même
vous venez une vous économisez orgue et
pendant dix ans pour acheter une montre
comme ça muna il me faut bien sûr
serveurs de temps on est de lui laurent
je crois que tu sais laurent fait ça
très bien pour un cutter plaisir des
chalands le métro pendant des années si
fait savoir ces sabres j'ai peur ce soit
trop mouna ayoub si vous étiez pauvres
vous joueriez de quels instruments de
musique dans le métro violent non comme
deviers joncour vous porteriez quel
vêtement si vous étiez pauvres ce que
j'aime parce qu'aujourd'hui on dirait un
pull noir qu'est ce qui vous moquerez le
plus mouna si vous étiez pour l'amour en
quoi cela gênait l'amour d'un gigolo
ça hyper bien merci pourquoi ne s'achète
pas la mouna pour la noirceur
aujourd'hui c'est incroyable
si vous étiez pauvres à qui empruntent
feriez vous de l'argent vous êtes avec
le crédit lyonnais madame oui je suis en
retraite occupé du crédit lyonnais
sadi clôture des pagnes populaires je
vous propose parfois tentée en
l'entendant excusez moi mais vous savez
que henri de france 2 le fils du comte
de paris est venu ici nous a parlé de
vous il était à la banque avec vous au
crédit lyonnais
il paraît qu'un jour on m'a interdit de
rentrer vous étiez piquet de grève
et vous lui avait interdit de rentrer
oui ça fait des bulles
je me souviens pas de lui mais on
essayait d'empêcher effectivement les
dirigeants de rentrer dans l'entreprise
quand on était en grève
oui alors à qui on compte auriez-vous de
l'argent si vous étiez pauvre mouna aux
membres aux membres de ma famille le
plus proche et le plus riche et plus
riche que moi est-ce que vous soyez
capable de vendre de la drogue si vous
étiez pauvres non très très pauvre
impossible impossible impossible même
des drogues douces est facilement un peu
pour un peu d'argent jamais vous
penseriez quoi des gens qui vivent seuls
dans 300 m² si vous étiez pauvre d'abord
j'irai essaie de trouver du boulot chez
eux ça les chambres de bonnes
oui est-ce que si vous étiez peau vous
voteriez pour l'extrême gauche
encore une fois ça dépend des objectifs
de l'extrême gauche 6 demander de
l'argent grosso modo aux couacs et puis
des traîtres et les chats tout le monde
perd de l'argent si on passe un petit
peu un petit peu il y en a qui bossent
et qu'on pas d'argent mais alors si
c'est pas la poste en tout cas à la fois
ce rapport signale par mois c'est moins
calmes enfin faut que j'arrête de
déconner sinon j'ai pu voir de courrier
chez moi tout ça c'est sûr plus de
factures non quoique ça ça a du bon mais
qui leur est il non sérieusement bien ça
me va ou pas voter voter si samba
gelable pour tous les gens disent que ça
me va très bien
vous feriez pour l'extrême-gauche vous
êtes cpo encore une fois je lis ça
dépend des objectifs que l'extrême
gauche mais quand les seniors l'objectif
ça serait que vous ne soyez moins
pauvres finalement c'est messi en
utilisant l'argent des riches non vous
être contre l'idée qu'on prenne aux
riches pour donner aux pauvres tout à
fait quand je suis attention envers ses
deux res pour
elle a bien sûr trouver un emploi pour
tout le monde et que les salaires soient
justes mais je suis plutôt pour le
travail mois mais l'idée qui des gens
par exemple viennent schiesser aussi
sont pour le travail
j'aimerais bien trouver mais l'idée muna
à l'idée qui est des gens qui l'aiment
600 mille francs par mois et d'autres
6000 francs est ce que ça vous choque ou
non ça me choque pas pas du tout mais
pourtant attendait excusez moi tout une
ânesse chrétienne en tant que chrétienne
c'est choquant ça non qui des gens qui
gagnent 6000 francs et doute 600000 non
encore une face à dépend de leur
capacité de ce qu'il faut autour ne peut
pas faire le même boulot il ya des gens
qui peuvent assumer une responsabilité
importante le pays a besoin de tous ces
gens là on pouvait pas payer tous ces
gens là même salaire le petit
travailleur tranquille que je suis comme
dirait ma fille très travaillée vérité
voilà je sais que en travaillant dur
très dur on gagne beaucoup moins une
fois de plus 6000 francs par mois que
certaines personnes que je croise à
neuilly quand foutent pas une et qui
gagnent beaucoup beaucoup d'argent
est-ce que
est-ce que vous avez la preuve qu ils ne
foutent rien il ya des spéculateurs à la
bourse vous savez c'est leur seul métier
qui place parce qu'une entreprise qui
ferme
et puisque même en faisant des bénéfices
il place hilares achète et pilar font
couler après et puis les maquis vivent
que de ça vous savez ça existait une
toute petite minorité de la population
je dis pas que c'est votre cas mais ça
existe mais ces gens-là ils travaillent
pas ils travaillent vraiment pas eux
célébraient parasites asie en acculant
vaidehi retraités les chômeurs et les
salariés c'est ça que je comprends pas
ce que je sais pourquoi tu dit pourquoi
tu dis démago parce que depuis tout à
l'heure je j'entends des choses qui me
font hurler quoi et je voulais
simplement lui dire une fois pour toutes
vous êtes un démagogue
pourquoi pourquoi parce que parce que
globalement à chaque fois monsieur
besancenot pour expliquer sa politique
prend et prendre des exemples sur des
petites exceptions dans la société
il en fait des généralités il essaie par
ce fait de monter les gens contre je ne
sais pas je ne sais quel patronale
auquel capitalisme est globalement bon
ben ça vaut rien secoué début mai
au moment discours il ya effectivement
une toute petite partie de la population
dont je parle mais c'est une infime
partie peut-être 1%
ça c'est pas mes chiffres à moi c'est
pas les chiffres je vais terminer juste
si tu peux attendre n'est pas c'est mon
choix donc je vais terminer d'accord
attentats temps mais c'est terminé je
fais c'est terminé je te dis 1% de la
population qui possède plus de 50 % des
richesses de ce pays
et moi mon discours c'est à dire qu'il
ya deux millions et demi de chômeurs il
ya 5 millions de pauvres et il ya 9
millions personnes aujourd'hui qui
vivent avec moins de 5000 francs par
mois c'est juste ça que je voulais juste
demandé à monsieur besancenot une chose
est ce qu'il existe des patrons qui ne
sont pas des salles aux dépens des
[__] des [__] des patrons se
revend qui a des patrons qui font
généreux qui sont tout ce que tu voudras
moi je te parle du patronat comme
collectif comme une un groupe social qui
existe
oui ou non dans la soie 6,7 contre le
patronat oui le medef par exemple sous
les wagons sont ne sont pas
fréquentables ça c'est non mais si si si
le but du jeu c'est d'essayer de me
faire dire merci merci que je veux
prendre tous les patrons c'est pas mon
discours bien par contre le patronat
comme groupe collectif
le medef il un projet de société pour
moi mais aussi pour toi mais je trouve
ça très bien qu'on va le public puisse
participation c'est normal ça s'appelle
tout le monde en parle bien alors si on
change
alors dernière question moon a pour qui
vous voteriez en fait si vous deviez
voter pour l'extrême gauche pour arlette
laguiller ou pour olivier besancenot a
posé ensemble nous je vais pas vous
présenter aux présidentielles quand même
oh ben ça a tant dit on a vu ça va
casser d'ici là
[Musique]
merci beaucoup merci d'avoir été avec
nous
ça va très bien merci moment comment
vous les trouvez alors arlette laguiller
et olivier besancenot oublier va si vite
alors ils vont parvenir à ce qu'on a
maintenant des cartes de bons clients
qu'on donne aux gens qui sont agréables
quand même bien comme ça et reviennent
avec leur carte quand ils veulent même
quand ils ont pas de promo quoi comment
voulez trouvait alors à très sympathique
il y connaît beaucoup de choses que je
connais pas c'est une icône et le matin
pour distribuer le courrier de s'écouter
je n'ai jamais fait alors franchement
vous êtes chez vous imaginer à l'époque
vous habitiez à neuilly d'état neuilly
le matin il est à neuilly lui voyez
arriver olivier besancenot avec le
courrier cassou lui fait annie bonjour
c'est tout prenez un café avec moi fait
un petit cadeau quand même l ai dit tu
as vu leur chicago pour les bonnes
oeuvres de la poste ils sont partis je
vais lui envoyer par mail aurapavant à
6,6
et maintenant
oui si fabien galthié
m
fabien galthié mesdames messieurs alors
fabien galthié bas 1 m 80 j ça pour vous
mener à un mètre 81 82 kg madame ex
capitaine de l'équipe de france de rugby
nommé meilleur joueur du monde par lee
ermey en 2002 champion de france cette
année avec le stade français demi de
mêlée le plus capé c'est bien qu'ils
aient eu le plus de sélections en équipe
de france laurent le plus capé
s'applaudit mesdames messieurs
et c'est vrai qu'il est très séduisant à
ce qu'elle tient non vous trouvez pas
moon à 8000 euros
alors j'ai mis ça avant vous
[Musique]
tragédie chante les bee gees parce que
c'est pas la joie
vous rentrez d'australie le mondial de
rugby s'était achevée le 20 novembre par
une défaite des français face aux
all-blacks 13,40 la pâte et la pâte et
dans le match pour la troisième place
qu'on appelle la finale des battus donc
la france est quatrième et loupe le
podium démarche
alors expliquez vous non mais je pense
que il faut surtout enfin la défaite
c'est surtout la défaite en demi-finale
qui est qui était difficile à vivre
parce que bon la petite finale c'est une
autre histoire métier pas là dans le
titillant ensuite ils ont fait jouer que
des remplaçants et non je crois je crois
pas qu'il faut enfin qu'ils fassent à
faire un procès aux joueurs qui jouent
et la petite finale c'est déjà je dirais
c'est différent parce que lorsqu'on se
prépare à tout durant quatre mois pour
une une compétition et qu'on a
l'ambition d'être champion du monde
lorsque vous perdez à la demi finale
demi-finales de la compétition et parce
qu elle terminée c'est vrai que le petit
chien est un match important mais mais
voilà c'est comme ça la défaite fait
partie des jeux enfin quand même des
cinq grandes nations du rugby
international
une seule n'a pas encore été championne
du monde c'est la france paraît que ça
va venir
c'est bien il reste des choses à même le
cameroun a gagné vous pensez que ça peut
arriver quand même moi je pense que bon
cette année on a perdu en demi finale il
ya quatre ans andré perrier en finale
face à l'australie et à 8 ans on avait
perdu en demi finale face aux
sud-africains à une baignade les cheveux
c'est pas loin
on n'est pas très loin on est passé donc
je crois que il reste peut-être dans
quatre ans la coupe du monde auront lieu
en france et peut-être l'équipe du
moment sont champions de l'afrique nepad
en quatre ans en tête dans huit ans
c'est tous les quatre ou dans 12 ans
voir venez ça va venir c'est là quand ça
se passe en france que la gagne et quand
même non il faut la gagner c'est vrai
mais le sport le sport c'est s'éteint
c'est un jeu on n'est pas sûr de gagner
à tous les coups et avons non
l'indécision fabien à commencer par
académie et organise ses différents quoi
vous n'auriez pas aimé rester jusqu'en
non mais moi je suis j'ai 34 ans je joue
depuis un long moment et je crois que je
suis arrivé je suis arrivé au bout du
chemin bien des cas cités ci-haut la
synapse à la révision des 5000 6ième cas
ces éléments venaient de se renseigner
elle regarde un peu comme ces derniers
n'ont que peu d'échos ki moon a rejeté
un peu mais ce que parfois qu'ils sont
de ses protégés vous protégez pas autant
que le sport américain
non mais l'américaine photo n'est pas on
n'est pas tes d'abord de gênant
justement moi je te protège pas trop
nombreux et là c'est pour ça qu'il ya
beaucoup de cas soirée à bonne fin des
traumatismes mais bon on est préparé
pour ça aussi donc non mais dans
l'ensemble ça va s'avérer plus des
mauvais coups dans les parties non non
non non ça va pour le moment savoir si
c'est vrai il ya des attouchements dans
les mêlées c'est quoi c'est une des
parties qui a pas été encore touché bon
d'attouchements ça peut arriver ça va
les mener
le vestiaire aussi way ou dans les
soirées fait un peu partout alors la
fédération va reconduire la porte le 13
décembre vous pensez je sais pas
reconduire à la porte
rené nan sérieux je ne sais pas c'est un
saint c'est un choix qui est qui incombe
au président et à son bureau mais moi je
pense que bernard des compétences fait
ce qu'ils pouvaient pour avoir la
meilleure équipe possible et il ya aussi
d'autres d'autres d'autres candidats
c'est certain mais
bon on n'a pas tourné les joueurs on n'a
pas tellement dans et on n'a pas
tellement à s'exprimer à ce sujet si
vous aurez plus de le remplacer
non pas de suite là je prends un peu de
recul de suite c'est vrai que je pense
que je reviendrai au terrain ans comme
entraîneur soit commun peut-être manager
je n'en sais rien parce que comme toi on
joue depuis l'âge de 7 ans et quoi quand
on a cette passion du ballon rond ben on
peut par ailleurs l on n'est pas bons il
faut que je suis bien c'est vrai que
j'ai la chance d'avoir à celle d'un
autre parce qu'elle y repasse à la
montre tout et mourtérot pour lui
montrer de quel est le montre me parles
tu es notre vie ma montre je n'ai pas de
montre
dites-moi sérieusement il faudra quand
même constituer une équipe pour 2007 qui
soit capable de jouer quand il pleut
parce qu'il paraît que vous avez perdu
la demi-finale parce qu'il pleuvait du
camembert nan ça c'est vrai c'est non
mais c'est d'abord on a perdu c'est vrai
que les conditions climatiques n'étaient
pas on n'a pas une équipe
vous pensez que séoul un joujou avec une
capuche vous avez des chances de gagner
ou le terrain couvert
non mais c'est vrai qu'on a une équipe
qui est qui qui manque qui manque au
fameux on va pas rentrer la stratégie
dans le ja v6 et n'en attendez moi on me
dit ils ont perdu la demi finale contre
les anglais parce qu'il pleuvait c'est
un truc qui arrive quand même la pluie
malheureusement une mauvaise météo c'est
tout le moral en relève à carey
vous chassez vous pêchez je pêche un
péché par excès alors comment on peut
perdre parce que l'herbe est mouillé le
terrain est gras à part du moment où ils
le
le ballon à un grip est difficile
d'attraper le ballon ça glisse est tout
à fait ce qui les inquiète pas trop
technique par et pour moi savoir qu'est
ce qu'elle est belle non non c'est à
dire que quand même bien le ballon
glissant il faut jouer différemment il
faut jouer à jouer la coupe est pleine
il joué très près les uns des autres et
à limiter le nombre de passes parce que
chaque à chaque pas sans risque de
tomber le ballon
nous on a un jeu fin des français on est
moins puissant que que l'écho les anglo
saxons on a un jeu qui est plus plus
dynamique plus plus basé sur la vitesse
et sur la vitesse d'exécution et c'est
vrai que pour faire des passes de
longues passes et rapide lorsque le
ballon glisse ça devient très compliqué
parce qu'un possible et donc il faut
changer de stratégie il faut jouer plus
près des gens et non pas ce nom est ce
qu'on appelle du défi r ce jeu là on est
en manque de puissance au même niveau le
disent quand ils bluffent au moins deux
passes
pour transport d'une autonomie bien sûr
bien sûr en général et les rugbymans il
pose nu d'habitude
non
[Musique]
tu te demandais ce que tu allais faire
dans la vie maintenant voilà on dirait
un album pour enfants une comptine muna
et fabien aventures de mounana parce que
fabien il a dit à bien il le dit dans le
rugby j'ai atteint mes limites et ça y
est vous en avez assez là ouais ouais
ouais je crois que j'ai fait tout ce que
je pouvais faire enfin j'ai pas de
regret quand je suis allé au bout de ce
que je pouvais faire bon j'ai pas été
champion du monde mais c'est pas faute
d'avoir essayé coin et ça c'est vrai
voilà vous avez plus jouer au rugby r
non je vous prie non il faut savoir
tourner la page parce que c'est vrai que
c'est jamais évident quand on a passé
toute sa vie à s'entraîner régulièrement
fait le récit des sensations que je
connaîtrai plus et ce matin je suis allé
voir mes camarades du stade français qui
préparer leur dernier entraînement pour
jouer demain et c'est vrai que ça m'a
fait quelque chose donc il vaut mieux
tourner la page radicalement plutôt que
savez dans le sport de haut niveau il
faut savoir s'arrêter au bon moment
parce que si vous faites l'année de trop
vous et préparez bien sûr votre
reconversion vous allez chez desseilles
canal + 1 1
la mairie de paris ouais voilà mais
désormais bon votre vie va être assez
vite quand même non mais non là je vais
déjà je m'en vais je commente un match
ce week-end pour canal donc c'est une
façon de rester assez proche de mon
sport et sans avoir aucune pression
essayer de continuer à vivre ma passion
l'émotion et puis essayer de faire
partager avec le plus grand nombre et
puis je crois que la ville de paris a de
grands projets notamment d'organiser la
coupe du monde 2007
les candidates aux jeux olympiques 2012
et ça c'est déjà fantastique a à faire
je pense que il ya de quoi faire alors
vous avez dit vous avez déclaré que le
rugby pro finalement maintenant ça fait
quand même beaucoup changé le rugby est
ce que si une des raisons de votre arrêt
comme ça de non au contraire je crois
que j'ai joué plus longtemps que prévu
parce que moi j'ai connu le rugby on
s'entraînait d'autres fois par semaine
et puis à partir de 95 ans s'entraîne
tous les jours puis après deux fois par
jour puis après on a mis des
préparateurs physiques en place on a mis
toute une stratégie de préparation ce
qui m'a permis de continuer à maintenir
un certain niveau de séquences de boulot
parce qu'avant il y avait dix plaquage
c'est vrai maintenant il ya type la
caserne à joué y avait dit mi temps
effectif de jeu mais tu t'en ailles à 40
1 20 après un match difficile c'était
souvent l'apéro d'après match alors que
maintenant il ya plus à pratiquement
plus apéro parce que le lendemain un
entraînement on était très bon à l'apéro
commencé c'était très dur les six mois
c'est que rugby en se professionnalisant
est devenu moins sympa non quand on
descend je pense qu'il ya toujours cette
atmosphère les valeurs du rugby c'est
c'est la convivialité c'est la
fraternité c'est le sait le don de soi
ses engagements c'est l'humilité il ya
beaucoup de valeur je trouve que c'est
un beau sport avec des valeurs des
belles valeurs
mais c'est vrai qu'au niveau haut niveau
on peut moins de faire la fête au moins
faire les cons mais si vous descendez en
deuxième division ou en un universitaire
il ya toujours cet esprit on chante
toujours des chansons après les matchs à
l'apéro c'est toujours à pouvoir le même
panier commence justement on va regarder
quelques images du calendrier 2004
[Musique]
non
je
c'est là qu'est
[Musique]
oui oui
il
chaque parent
mt
nous
et
soir
elle a
m
déclare
[Musique]
j'ai
c'est le making-of du cadre
les dieux du stade j'ai beau dauphin qui
magnifie français seront vraiment vous
avez vu ça vous les connaissiez les mecs
du nord-est où vous voulez et encore ça
c'est des perdants
[Rires]
tu as bien il va tout les intérêts bien
ouais je sais il faut venir à jean bouin
jours le samedi et vous verrez tout le
monde les femmes peuvent y aller bien
sûr elles sont elles sont très bien
accueillis dans des cocktails
ils seront pas nul hein légèrement vêtu
légèrement vêtues après c'est à vous de
faire un chèque ou de séduire nos
seniors vous êtes plutôt footballeur
houdmann vous moi je dis ça je suis
plutôt rugby même parce que j'adore le
football américain nous convient oui
c'est moche absolument c'est très proche
sauf que bien sûr le football américain
énormément de protection dont il me faut
un autre a dit non elle est dans un état
pareil ça vous a fait
c'est très posé
il y avait une mise en scène votre
téléphone même moi qui suis hétéro ça me
rappelle quelque chose c'est magique
c'est vraiment beau des avis et vous ça
vous excite pas du tout ça m'amuse
mais mu n'a passé franchement
n'appartient pas rester entre copains
ces contrats le prochain calendrier d'un
parent essai pour commencer 2004 et on
va faire un fait ils font mais dites moi
quelle heure quinze jours
j'accueille maintenant armande altaï
[Musique]
tout le rallye monte bonsoir monde
brossard est heureux de vous voir voilà
laurent ce que j'ai rarement vu laurent
non mais tu fais des choses qui est là
tout est calé un cépage compliqué ça
s'appelle la galanterie ce tout petit
c'est bien c'est très bien de très bons
pardon tête a pas été violent avec moi
tu veux combat de la loge pas dit
mercier est ce que vous connaissez les
le calendrier des du stade français moi
oui non si vous aimez les boues du
bonhomme très bien très bien fait très
bien monté non pas votre truc
non non je lorsque chaque fois que j'ai
été séduit par un acteur c'était pas un
athlète c'était quelque chose de
mystérieux qui se passait là vous êtes
cérébrale plutôt vous marmande je ne
sais pas peut-être je fais mais l'animal
aussi un très bel animal
pourquoi riez vous parce que c'est un
sportif parce qu'on ne les comprend pas
ce qu'on dit les rugbymen
je trouve qu'il avait qu'avec son est
tout plat comme ça dans l'alignement du
front il a un profil à la cocteau
méfie-toi football comme un c'est vrai
ça promet il ya bien voter jean marc ela
bien alors mort de taxes et la prof de
chant de la star ac on ne vous présente
plus vous étiez sur le plateau de la
star ac et encore une dizaine de minutes
vous êtes là maintenant il magie de la
télévision
les rentrées dit et des taxis 3
comment venir le château jusqu'ici c'est
absolument incroyable
vous faisiez vous êtes venu parce que
vous étiez la main sur le plateau la saq
non grand sérieux j'avais terriblement
envie de vous voir c'est gentil ça fait
une paye la merde way we et me l'a dit
juste avant oui en tout cas on est ravis
on va parler du livreur montrent que
vous publiez vie vous vous raconter
votre vie
mais auparavant quelques mails de
téléspectateurs qui savait que vous
veniez ce soir frédéric sicot de bollène
dans le vaucluse
armande est ce que vous faites prof de
chant à la star ac pour l'argent ou pour
le plaisir et l'honneur de découvrir des
talents comme jean pascal
pour les deux maintenant voler deux
c'était une aventure maintenant c'est
pour les deux alors tania roeg de
strasbourg pourquoi la star ac vous dit
pas tout de suite qui va gagner
et parce que c'est on ne sait pas ah bon
c'est les gens qui votent et l'intérêt
c'est que ce soit le plus grand nombre
de gens qui votent qui se sont ceux qui
vont acheter donc moins de 13 % des gens
n'y croient pas oui mais ça c'est parce
que c'est truqué
je crois que dans quelque chose de
truquer la télé ça se sait très vite il
ya parmi des jeux des jeux intervilles
ou un truc comme ça je pense que
maintenant plus personne prendrait le
risque
dominique gastou de nîmes vous trouvez
pas que ce car le prof de théâtre il
joue un peu comme une saucisse cd m les
téléspectateurs non non oscar moi je les
ai vus dans un spectacle magnifique
daria ce qui serait morte à des là il
était très bien lancé bernard viviani de
chamonix armande c'est vrai que nikos
aliagas crois que john lennon va venir
la semaine prochaine
non bien bruno d'heure de paris a oui ça
c'est plus grave
armand est ce que votre coiffure c'est
suite à un pari
ah là là s'il m'avait vu il ya quelques
années
bon françois alors lui je ne sais pas
comment il s'appelle françois sauvadet
de cherbourg j'ai retrouvé les chansons
que vous chantiez dans les années 80 est
ce que vous prenez des trucs à l'époque
non pas trop
[Musique]
stop ou encore ça ressemble à klaus nomi
un peu
c'était important
[Musique]
je vais vous dire moi
moi je vais bien encore une fois je
demande dans cette émission compass
l'église que la vitesse normale alors
armande vous publié chez jean claude
lattès votre autobiographie qui
s'appelle cette musique qui me vient de
loin
et effectivement on voit en lisant ça
que vous avez une vie beaucoup plus
drôle que les gens de la star ac' d'une
vie incroyable d'une richesse absolument
extraordinaire alors on y va
vous êtes né en mai 44 à alep en syrie
espèce de forteresse médiévale voilà où
est pas loin de chez vous un en syrie
alep
voilà votre père officier français votre
mer orientale
votre mère descendait d'un bep turc qui
descendait lui-même des sultans voilà et
comme christian vadim la semaine
dernière lui descendait de gengis camp
mais vous aussi vous descendez de gengis
khan par votre mère est peut-être par an
avec les sens l'a10 main draw qu avec
catherine deneuve bien alors votre mère
vous transmet l'amour de la musique ah
oui c'est de la coiffure également tort
elle était très sobre toujours toujours
pendu alario sérieusement c'est vrai ma
mère écouter écouter radio le caire
ouais
tous les soirs elle s'endormait sur la
voie doom donc haletant
quoi
c'est pas vous mais il était tout blanc
vous endormir en écoutant ça tous les
soirs bon oui ouais et pas seulement
nous en norme en longueur de journée on
écoute et c'est alors le père était une
caricature de militaires c'était
vraiment le militaire type
vie au clairon et élevage à la cravache
un peu non c'est vrai ouais c'était un
homme formidable en même temps parce
qu'il est et il savait tout faire y lui
non ils jouent un football est très bien
il était maître nageur il était maître
d'équitation les chevaux arrivés allure
au souffle il est dirigé à l'oreille des
chevaux
oui oh c'est oui face on avait un petit
sachet les cosaques justement dans la
famille de ma grand-mère suffirait à
lasser et ils étaient tous une sorte de
héros par l'extérieur mais très très dur
quand même à ça on a tous des ombres en
nous et il ya des gens qui cultivent ces
ombres parce qu'elles servent dans
l'armée on cultive quelques fois les ans
ensuite vous quittez donc le moyen
orient votre famille part vivre en côte
d'ivoire et là vous avez une enfance
comme ça de petites negri jochen admin
oui c'est ça c'est vrai 2000 lui avec un
qui s'appelait coco donc c'est tout ça
c'est rien des minots nos copeaux on
voit les images les images et les
mangues et sur la route de la mission
comme mais c'est vrai qu'à cette époque
les baoulé n'était pas habillée elle
sera bien à l'époque qu'ils avaient des
colliers était très souvent nue donc
nous sommes vous aussi voilà et alors ce
coco ce qu'on commet là c'est très grave
ce coco d'or devant la chambre des
enfants et en fait on comprend à demi
mot d'ailleurs en lisant votre livre qui
protéger les enfants et surtout votre
soeur contre les assauts de votre père
est ce que je me suis trompé ou pas en
lisant le bouquin non c'est un petit peu
comme ça hein
est ce que il ya eu des choses avec
votre soeur nilda à l'époque c'est ce
que je dis dans le livre
en tout cas ce qu'on lit dans le livre
c'est que votre soeur a été éloigné et
qui aura plus jamais de cohabitation
avec votre père voilà alors l'été 49
vous arrivez à marseille où vous dites
que vous fabriquez vos racines
votre père lui a way d'auteur
votre père lui par en indochine et vous
avez de moins en moins de nouvelles de
lui vous êtes là avec votre mère et les
enfants
il disparaît complètement donc
évidemment vous êtes mise à l'école
publique parce qu'il ya plus de blé et
puis ça devient dur la vie quoi
d'épicier refuse de vous servir et tout
ça concernait la galère la wii ouais
mais c'est j'en ai pas souvenir trop
tragique parce que notre mère avait
choisi de le plus d'argent qu'elle avait
c'était pour la musique les disques le
cinéma alors ça choquait beaucoup nos
petites copines parce que elle n'allait
jamais au cinéma mais vous avez les
petits jupon en nylon à la mode
les petites chaînes en or et nous on
faisait comme notre mère en ses rangs se
promener comme si on était en robe de
bal même si on avait des choses très
très vieille sur le dos et mais par
contre avant de raconter les films qu'on
joué chez nous on était très acteurs
très très danseurs et chanteurs la bande
des frères et soeurs et les petites
camarades nous suivait alors on faisait
exprès de pas dire la fin tout de suite
vous allez coquette elle nous suivait
pour savoir la fin de l'histoire et non
les plaignants ont dit mais vous n'allez
jamais au cinéma au pauvre petite heure
d'été très et c'est long c'est comme ça
que vous découvrez mahalia jackson qui a
été évidemment très importante pour vous
dans votre carrière de chanteuse plus
tard alors voilà ces devises passe à
marseille quand vous avez dix ans un
jour votre père envers les mecs sont
gonflés j'aurais jamais osé faire ça le
mec qui se barre il revient bol de la
ferme et de s'écraser
il revient avec deux vietnamienne bas
une deux oui non mais c'est incroyable
quand même si c'est un culot absolument
phénoménale non pourquoi pour mettre ça
dans la bibliothèque pour tous
non mais c'est vrai et trois enfants oui
quel culot quand même dans une
sérieusement entre temps on a appris
qu'il y en avait d'autres
ouais on a eu des nouvelles d'autres
personnes par an faut dire aussi que les
vietnamiennes sont toujours disponibles
ah bon vous avez sous la main aussi mona
mais oui ah bon non mais c'est
incroyable personnellement mes amis
presque
je ne sais pas ce qui leur a dit pour
pour qu'elle ait l'air surprise aussi le
trouver une famille d'accueil elle aussi
oui alors votre maire tombe de
s'empoisonner à ce moment là oui avec
des baguettes et là et le père re
disparaît presque aussitôt
et là où il est encore plus gonfler sa
disparaît quelques années plus tard il
vient chercher l'argent pour vanter un
resto avec les deux vietnamiens un
restaurant chinois et et vous êtes
obligé de vendre l'appartement où vous
habitez et vous installer dans un
quartier très excentré voilà c c c'est
fou quand on voit ça non en plus nous
étions des étrangères parce que ma mère
était turc
eris mélanger nous nous étions des des
petites orientale aussi on a appris le
français doucement on avait des accents
donc on nous regardait de travers et dès
qu'on dise est notre père est militaire
tout de suite à nous recevait donc
quelque part c'était une position très
ambiguë parce que on est et on était un
petit peu un pack un petit peu nous
étions ses victimes et en même temps la
scène ont rejoint le reconnaissez quand
même comme quelqu'un de heureusement qu'
à ce père est officier pour pour
attraper la famille locale salaires
chinois
c'est incroyable et à 18 ans vous marier
avec un type un homme plus âgé que vous
qui vous a dit je t'aime quoi la dette
passe comme ça il a su trouver les mots
qua non mais c'est vrai dit exactement
le mot je t'aime et magic lui fort que
celui qui le dit on a tellement besoin
de l'entendre que lorsqu'on est jeune et
quelqu'un vous dit vous traite d'une
certaine manière vous regarde vous avez
l'impression d'exister et on se trompe
c'est le mot je t'aime qui est plus fort
que la personne qui les a été touché par
son regard vous dis oui c'est je sais
pas pourquoi j'aime les hommes brun au
regard triste et toujours mais cette
fois j'ai de la diva trash ça c'est un
regard on va dire un essai la bagarre
risque il un regard malicieux nommé dit
les mots magiques les mots je t'aime
j'ai désolé pas bien il va bien voir
mais c'est vrai il était dans l' angle
là il a reçu aussi il est beau tout va
bien c'est magnifique dis moi je te
balance plus sympa je te trouve sympa ah
c'est bien bien et alors donc vous vous
mariez évidemment le lendemain matin là
c'est mon slip absolue vous vous
réveillez dans une chambre est misérable
petite chambre ike turner époques
changent pas de vous traduire chambrette
c'est un endroit très petit raid pour
une petite chambre c'est une petite
chance dans des rôles
sauf que mouna moi je vous connais
suffisamment pour savoir que quand vous
êtes arrivé à paris elle été laissée aux
bons était serveuse chez l ennemi ni
chambre est oui c'est lagardère et c'est
là qu'un soin dans un restaurant elle a
vu arriver le saoudien avec la blonde
way est une chaîne a pris leurs menus
sans la blanche
je crois qu'on peut le dire d'après son
coach et blanc on n'a pas ce qu'elle
aurait pu rester
bien doit vous vous réveillez dans une
chambrette de la branche et puis
courageusement vous dites faut y aller
quand vous montez à paris avec votre
mari chez son frère à lui votre beau
frère
je suis vraiment un mauvais chiens mais
un connard j'ai jamais vu ça vous avez
envie de vous dire là je suis sûr qu'il
nous regarde non mais c'est c'est eh non
mais c'était léger mieux carences de
notre pauvre de ma génération
c'étaient des hommes normaux ah oui à
l'époque c'était ça les mecs
voilà en fait mannequin parce que vous
avez un une tête à chignon quoi c'était
la mode des voilages chinian pompadour
en 68 à l'époque faisait dans une grande
femme
maintenant c'est différent vous êtes
mannequin à ce moment là effectivement
vous commencez à faire un petit peu pour
la coiffure pour la mode tout ça vous
commencez un petit peu a fréquenté le
tout-paris armande et votre mari et ça
c'est terrible pour vous garder à la
maison il vous met enceinte
oui c'est aussi quelque chose qui se
faisait avant c'était pas extraordinaire
non quelque part il a bien fait et vous
un jour c'est dans un jardin public
et là vous accouchez nord j'ai pas lu de
livre jeu peu évident non je paie du
temps je me suis détaché le bouquet tu
devrais lire je glande ans par an dont
la réussite est ce que tu pourrais pas
le temps d'essai lui lui toujours il est
là il faut rien pour rien je sais pas
alors donc je vois une petite fille avec
un petit garçon qui lui prend un objet
joie la petite fille qui boude et sa
meute or le coeur mais c'est terrible
j'ai un espèce de choc que je sais pas à
quoi c'est dû je ne me l'expliqué
toujours pas et j'ai compris que ce
serait mon enfant serait comme ça j'ai
eu la même
voilà j'ai reconnu alors que j'étais au
début de ma grossesse j'ai reconnu
l'enfant que j'allais avoir c'était une
petite fille comme ça me brunette et
j'ai dit c'est la mienne
bon d'accord elle préfigure l enfant
voilà qu'elle est en virginie est arrivé
c'était exactement voilà celle là celle
là la même c'est incroyable cette
histoire j'en suis écoute
ces voiles alors ensuite fait des petits
boulots dj vais vous chanter des
chansons dans les restos vous retournez
dans le sud de la france chantait à
cassis vous faites un concours de talent
local destiné à trouver des candidats
pour le jeu de la chance il est
extraordinaire dans toute cette histoire
c'est qu'armand vous avez fait le jeu de
la chance c'est à dire que finalement
vous avez fait d'astarac de l'époque
quoi suis je n'ai pas fait un défi oui
j'aimerais bien vous deviez j'ai créé le
concours des fois c'est le jeu qui a
permis de découvrir à mireille mathieu
thierry le luron
mais en fait vous le faites pas vous y
renoncer oui pourquoi
et parce que j'étais déjà j'avais déjà
un vieux août stoxx a eu plein de choses
et j'ai compris tu es pas la musique que
je voulais faire je m en veux tu dire
comme georgette lemaire
je ne savais pas s'il y avait une
ouverture pour le genre de musique que
je faisais qui était complètement
étrange bouffe vous monter à paris en
abandonnant votre mari est votre enfant
non je les abandonne pas je les ai
jamais aimé de lui avant mais c'est ce
que j'en sais rien dans le mari et le
mari je comprends mais l'enfant mais oui
je pensais revenir plus souvent ou la
vraie plus souvent ou qui me l'amènerait
c'est vrai mais je n'ai jamais abandonné
j'ai toujours travaillé et envoyer de
l'argent et s'est toujours occupée
d'elle vous dresser comme une année sans
avoir virginie il ya eu presque deux ans
où je n'ai pratiquement pas vu parce
qu'il a mené pas parce que les choses ne
se faisait pas et donc j'ai je suis
quasiment aller l'enlever avec l'aide
d'une avocate
alors voilà donc à paris c'est un petit
peu la galère vous étés l'échelle de
jacob mais vous êtes vestiaires et vous
êtes violée parmi eux sera violet déjà
comme c'est l'échelle de richter ont été
prises on veut saute dessus et m'ont ne
viole pas je ne serais pas laisser faire
c'est que je sais qui c'est orlando
exigent non non c'est un auteur que vous
admiriez beaucoup oui et un jour il vous
sautent dessus j'ai rendez vous avec lui
oui il arrache vos vêtements enfin c'est
vraiment bestial comme comme histoire
vous arrivez à vous enfuir
on ne sait pas comment un auteur de qu
un dramaturge un auteur de chansons à
des chansons que jerry kelly services ou
non non non ne vous dit pas le nom dans
le livre
rien n'a pas 50 1 avec des yeux de
batraciens
vous dites ça dans mon cas oui c'est son
regard caché un regard de batraciens et
que vous le croisez encore d'un oeil
pétillant qui après à ce moment là comme
tous les hommes qui vont venir du voile
est d'accord je veux dire que moi je
dirai après enfin je pouvais voter façon
qui ne dit mot consent je crois qu'un
bon je dis ni nom ni oui parce que ça
peu après ça on procède par élimination
1 ce soir je ne répondrai pas à mende
c'est là que je le sais je n'ai rien dit
ni oui ni non parce qu'ils sont morts et
ont répondu oui on va procéder par
élimination
d'accord il a trouvé et c'est pas le
même 1 ce qui sait sa as
bravo non non non non non les ippons le
dit pas c'est ça c'est ça
il est passé à autre chose
voilà donc vous pouvez envoyer les noms
sur le site france2
le gagnant aura une soirée entière avec
armande altaï voilà c'est la moindre des
choses
donc ça c'est l'époque montmartre à ce
moment là vous faites la manche un petit
peu dans les restos en chantant et
jouant de la guitare et là vous tombez
sur un mec extraordinaire qui est
milliardaire alors vous découvrez un
jour d'ailleurs qu'il a une femme et des
enfants
mais la nuit vient rôder là il aime
passer ses c'est donc avec vous c'était
pas le même la journée c'était quelqu'un
que je ne connaissais pas c'est ça et
pendant très longtemps de ses vues que
la nuit
l' or la nuit on se parlait presque pas
en chuchotant seulement on se comprenait
à demi mot il y avait une espèce de il
était on était sur tous les deux qu'on
était jamais glucides et on se voyait
jamais le juste au regard donc c'est une
autre personnalité
un autre personnage ouais alors il veut
vous à installer il veut produire vos
disques et à soleil m'intéresse plus
vous refuse évidemment autres ensuite
s'est engagé dans le gospel ou fait la
rencontre de daniel auteuil de dave et
azul en armant de vous retrouver le
milliardaire qui revient et on là il
peut vous offrir à une star de la
chanson que vous appelez dans les
mystères mister c'est ce milliardaire
devenu connu avant il vous présente à ce
mystère mystère qui est très amoureux de
vous oui il le dit mais je sais pas si
je bats il pleure mais on vous embrasse
et oui mais claire sur autre chose
ouais tous les cas vous êtes très ému
par lui quand même un oui parce que j'ai
senti que
tout d'un coup c'était il y avait
quelque chose de grave qui m'échappe et
que je ne comprenais pas et il y avait
une sorte de petite voix intérieure qui
me disait sauve toi reste pas là cours
forrest comment la série parce que la
même chose alors si une énorme star ce
type arbre l'appeler mystère mystère
c'est une énorme star je vous demande
l'a reconnu évidemment non je vais vous
dire
je suis désolé on veut pas le dire sinon
on a des procès après on s'attendrait
pas une énorme star très malheureuse
énorme sur la chanson française
on n'est plus là qui nous a quittés trop
tôt c'est lui non elle et elle ne dit
pas qui c'est mais je me dis qu'il sait
pas si j'arriverai toute façon bien
voilà bon donc voilà donc vous ne cédez
pas à vous partez sans faire l'amour
avec lui je sais pas une fille facile
voire mandat il est encore prouvé il a
trouvé à chaque adresse
voilà enfin encore mieux vous l'avez
compris c'est un livre il a trouvé
presque que le prénom viendra ah non
c'est un prénom il y en a plusieurs
ouais bien donc voilà donc j'arrête ma
corps le livre est très très intéressant
c'est une vie incroyable non quel bilan
vous tiré de cette vie aujourd'hui là ça
c'était avant la star ac' encore un abri
à toutes la star ac mais ça va je suis
contente de moi j'ai traversé une petite
tempête suis entêtée dans certaines
choses d'ailleurs c'est je dis souvent
que mes défauts et mes qualités sont les
mêmes c'est l'entêtement et l'orgueil
c'est c'est des défauts et des qualités
aussi voilà dites moi alors la semaine
dernière là tout le monde était
passionné par le conseil de discipline
pour pierre est ce que vous pensez qu'il
va faire la tournée d'été plus la france
entière se demande
je ne sais pas si la fra moi je trouve
que c'est c'est eh il est jeune il est
sorti avec beaucoup de panache et c'est
artistiquement c'était très bon
simplement quand quand on a des
responsabilités artistique il faut faire
attention
à ne pas laisser ses petits camarades en
cours de route c'est comme si lui quitté
le match au milieu c'est ce qu'il a fait
que c'est ce qu'il a fait d'ailleurs il
est parti avant le dernier match bien
une chose que je dis pas c'est que dans
votre bouquin amende vous parlez de moi
mais là j'aurai la discrétion évidemment
de pas mais c'est vrai parce qu'il s'est
passé quelque chose at elle dit des
trucs sympas sur moi ce disque hot du
palace tout ça non c'est très sympa il
s'est passé quelque chose
à une époque où vous étiez un des
personnages de cette époque c'est à dire
que tous les coups la nuit a changé il
n'y a plus il n'y avait plus les friqués
entre qui revenait de saint-tropez dans
des petites boîtes
tout d'un coup il y avait plein plein de
gens de tous les milieux sociaux qui se
rencontrent et il y avait des des gens
de banlieue qui croisaient les sex
pistols ou des gens high tech ou
c'est incroyable fabrice merdes qui a
lancé tout
j'appelle ça les nuits mais 2 et voilà
voilà et vous étiez là et vous avez créé
ces nouvelles tokyo comme ça un peu
people un peu branché rock
je suis dans le vide dans le monde voilà
c'est jean collin
[Musique]
alors laurent me demande où chamina
montre que qu'est ce que c'est que ces
dix ans d'âge à les déposer dans la loge
de mouna la norme en train d'être là
je marchais avec le changer ça va
trouver de la chair bien t'as pas vu
t'as rien ce soir devant attente aura
trois molières fort sur mer celtique et
riz moi j'ai un projet les chaises je
veux dire bouna non j'étais c'est
pourquoi parce qu'on gèle ici c'est vrai
merci gabriel de mario kart et combien
sur le yacht en effet à ce que tu fais
beaucoup plus chauffer tout de même
merci il ya des mecs là va très bien
voiture en la montre oui c'est bien non
c'est bien laurent lapeyre gadio toi ça
sera bien sûr être viendra t elle montre
un beau yacht on s'y fait très facile
j'ai eu le temps de changer les voyages
à lui de pacotille et maintenant non non
non non non non non non non temps morts
est maintenant de temps mort enfin temps
mort attend c'est bon que l'on sait
qu'on appelle une choucroute
[Musique]
cette rentrée tic et tac faut ni salir
et victor rigoles ou quoi
enlève ton ailleurs on s'endette on
avance oui pardon moon arrivé sur le
plateau les scouts et marine échappe à
sa fin sur mesure et maintenant
[Musique]
et vous
voici matthew smith
tu smith bonsoir bonsoir du yo-yo me
vous m'entendez régulière et je vous
entends cinq sur cinq
voilà mes airs mais c'était en quoi sa
tête ne touche mais c'était encore un
tome hitomi bravo des moutons millet ou
[Applaudissements]
120 points donc armande altaï qui est
prof de chant l'astarac matthew énorme
une star nationale en france elle a fait
trente ans de travail super belles
chansons et s'est donné un mal de chien
et est devenu star avec la star ac voilà
il raconte sa vie non non service
banques n'ont pas toujours facile quand
on sait que notre hôte en commun
alors je vous présente mouna ayoub et
fabien galthié mariés de l'an iii
certain matthew
mathieu savard tout cas vis dans le pâté
toi je comprends je comprends le stade
bien celle là ça va oui ça va c'est vrai
ça va ça va kiffer la trad
c'est robert bon ça va reverser robert
j'ai d'abord c'est ça va ça va robert
bien serge savard qu'un crime ça va très
bien dans tout le monde leur doit y
aller alors donc vous publiez matthew
smith chez plon un bouquin qui s'appelle
victimes
les dernières révélations de marilyn
monroe et oui parce qu'on croyait tout
savoir et on ne savait pas tout alors
pour faire simple la mort de marilyn ya
plusieurs thèses et la thèse du suicide
marine monroe s'est suicidé en absorbant
une dose massive de barbituriques d'une
un but a lancé la version disant
pratiquement officiel il ya une autre
thèse c'est qu'elle a été poussé au
suicide voire assassinés par des frères
kennedy
parce qu'après avoir été la maîtresse de
john et bob kennedy elle en savait trop
sur leurs liens avec la mafia est elle
menacée par les bref elle devenait
incontrôlable ça c'est les thèses
d'hydrocution discuté jusque là et votre
thèse matthew smith c'est encore une
autre thèse une troisième thèse en fait
les coupables sont des dissidents de la
cia qui ont été furieux de l'échec de la
tentative de débarquement anti castriste
à cuba dans la baie des cochons et qui
pour se venger aurait assassiné marilyn
monroe pour [__] les kennedy dans la
mer pour se venger de cet échec et
ensuite il aurait d'ailleurs organisé
l'assassinât de john kennedy de son
frère bob et il aurait compromis edward
kennedy l'autre avec mary jo kopechne
est la fameuse affaire de chappaquiddick
quand eux
il tente dans une rivière avec mary jo
kopechne et voilà alors effectivement
meurtre organisé par des dissidents de
la cia pour se venger de l'échec de la
baie des cochons c'est votre théorie qui
a su c'est ma théorie oui et oui a en
fait vous avez présenté sa manière
absolument brillante
je sais que la cia ont été impliquées
dans cette affaire parce que l'année
suivante lors d'assassinats de hadjadj
et après j'ai un témoin oculaire
quelqu'un qui était constaté médias avec
quelqu'un qui a reconnu qu'il était
membre de la cia et qui a dit à mon
indicateur la veille de l'assassinât
kenji qu'il serait assassinée lorsqu'il
viendrait à dallas et c'est ce qui s'est
passé et puis il m'a dit que bob kennedy
à son kiné trouverait la mort et c'est
ce qui s'est passé ainsi alors est
quelque chose qui se dégage on commence
à avoir
une situation qui se répète c'était la
troisième tentative de se débarrasser
des canaux dit qu'il faut dire que ce
que dit matthew smith s'est finalement
tout ça ne commence pas avec
l'assassinât de john fitzgerald kennedy
à dallas mais en fait ça commence avec
l'assassinât de marie line en 62 par ces
dissidents la cia ensuite john
fitzgerald kennedy ensuite bob kennedy
et ensuite l'histoire avec edward
kennedy dont caçapa d'iquique donc ce
que vous dites en fait que c'est une
opération de plus de plus grande ampleur
et qui date depuis plus longtemps que ce
qu'on croyait en fait d'être c'est
exactement ça oui et puis en plus sûrs
qu'ils voulaient se débarrasser de gfk
était absolument déterminés ils
voulaient absolument s'en débarrasser
ils ont vu l'occasion de le faire parce
que bob kennedy à l'époque fréquenté
marilyn monroe
il était chez elle deux fois la veille
de sa mort ils se sont disputés de
manière épouvantable c'est exactement ce
que voulaient les assassins alors il y
avait tout était sur table des coups
tous les écouter la maison était
entièrement sur table dès août la lfb la
cia et même la mafia arrêté rue des
micros partout tout le tour
et puis bien des années plus tard quand
quelqu'un a acheté la maison en question
il fallait procéder à des réparations
c'est du plafond et c'est là qu'on a
découvert des états de deux micros de
deux fils partout des gens qui écoutent
et a maintenant on est beaucoup plus fin
que ça on arrive à bien planqué les
micros à l'époque ce n'était pas juste
un petit truc tu fais tes petits câbles
partout des émetteurs partout mais voilà
donc cet assassinat d'après votre thèse
évidemment qui n'engage que vous
évidemment mais en tous les cas
marilyn monroe a été assassiné pour
mettre les kennedy dans la merde quoi
finalement
et non pas par les kennedy ouais c'est
ça c'est ça que vous dites
alors dans ce livre vous parlez aussi de
cassettes de cassettes sont enregistrées
par marilyn
greenson le psy de marilyn monroe la
voyait en séance de thérapie jusqu'à
deux fois par jour mais comme elle était
toujours bloquée comme on n'arrivait pas
à bien se raconter
il lui avait dit bah écoute et
enregistrez vous s'il a été tenu en même
temps mais bon enregistrez vous tout
seul avec un avec un magnétophone ce
qu'elle avait fait et donc aujourd'hui
vous dites-vous en tous les cas avoir
des informations qui remontent à ces
fameuses bandes magnétiques par
l'intermédiaire de quelqu'un à qui elles
ont été racontées je dis bien que ces cd
cd récit on est bien d'accord cela le
psychiatre intune arrêté et interrogé le
ministre adjoint de la justice le
procureur m il lui a dit ban ou marlene
s'est pas suicidé alors évidemment
c'était pas très concluants et puis
surtout pour un psychiatre c'est bon
c'est ça la fout mal quand son camp son
client se suicide
alors il ya des bains il m'a dit voilà
il lui a dit plutôt écouter ses
cassettes et si vous les écoutez vous
serez convaincu yen ne cédera suscité
alors il les a écoutés soigneusement il
a pris des notes et moi j'ai eu accès à
la transcription de 5 à 7
la personne qui écoutait ses cassettes
voilà c'est donc des retranscriptions
finalement non attester d'un
enregistrement présumé à liège c'est
vrai c'est vrai je veux enfin quand même
l'impression qu'il ya beaucoup de choses
semblent aller dans le sens de la preuve
n'est qu'affaire seul qui m'a donné des
transcriptions est devenu un avocat très
respecté aucun d'eux apparemment très
crédible quand même alléchant jeunesse
est anodine amoureux pourquoi aurait-il
eu monter cet intérêt toutes pièces il
n'avait aucune raison de faire croire
que ces pièces étaient authentiques si
elle ne l'était pas et puis oui et puis
enfin si l'on lit ces retranscriptions
ah oui
un souhait que d'autres personnes ont
dit et cela correspond exactement au
discours de marine et notre macho for
you c'est une bien de bambilor victimes
en toi tu as pas rater je dis là laurent
il al hayat et qui voit un bon client il
lui donne sa carte absolument c'est très
gentil alors on apprend quoi dans votre
bouquin à matthew smith
on apprend que marilyn monroe était
super admiratif de john fitzgerald
kennedy ma un point absolument
inimaginable dit marilyn monroe est un
soldat son commandant j'aimerais vous
prenez de la graine les finitions
commandant en chef est l'homme le plus
grand et le plus puissant du monde voilà
donc elle était très amoureuse de
kennedy on en a la preuve à travers les
trains des bandes
elle parle de son mari joe dimaggio
qu'elle a qu'elle a aimé beaucoup qui
est un joueur de baseball joe dimaggio
qui était le seul qui est venue à son
enterrement mais ça pouvait pas marcher
entre eux parce que lui il voulait une
épouse traditionnel un petit peu
comprenez pas que sa femme soit une star
c'est ça l'histoire qu'elle soit la
bonne femme au foyer avec le tablier qui
fasse la cuisine à la maison qui
reprises les chaussettes et ça ça lui
plaisait pas trop
cela étant tout semble l'indiquer
lorsqu'on lit on à foin des
transcriptions qu'elle comptait revenir
frère joe dimaggio et il a même été dit
qu'ils allaient se remarier le
mercredi qui a suivi en fait la plus
ferme et parce que c'est y enterrer à la
voilà donc c'est vrai que joe dimaggio
haute voix qui c'est joe dimaggio
c'était le point fixe un petit peu de
marilyn monroe
elle parle d'un autre de ses hommes
arthur miller grands auteurs dramatiques
américain en fait elle dit en parlant de
lui la chose ne l'intéressait pas
beaucoup le sexe n'était pas le truc
d'arthur miller c'est une des raisons
pour lesquelles ça se passait mal
et alors elle dit je simulais un plaisir
exceptionnelle pour qu'ils se montrent
plus entreprenants
voilà alors il ya une histoire d'âme
aucun scoop énorme est ce que je sais
pas si notre téléspectateurs se
souviennent de john crawford john
crawford une actrice qui jouait dans
johnny guitar qui était très haut masse
comme ça qu'ils avaient les cheveux
courts noirs qui étaient très très très
masculine et effectivement on apprend
que cette john crawford a une liaison
homosexuelle avec marilyn monroe et à un
moment à l'autre lui saute dessus un
petit peu comme vous avec votre notre
hauteur et et crawford lui saute dessus
elle fonce entre jeu parce qu'elles font
exactement mais elle dit en tous les cas
crawford john crawford a eu un
gigantesque orgasme et elle a crié comme
une folle pour la cedh en 60 ans excusez
moi à matthew c'est dans la version
anglaise de son livre dans la version
française ça a été supprimé sa version
portugaise ils ont coupé les poils aussi
marilyn monroe était était curieuse et
voulez tenter l'expérience je sais que
les gens se posent la question est est
ce le savoir si marine a été tentée par
lesbianisme et puis en fait là
effectivement on le sait des lésions
directement de l'intéressé qu'elle avait
essayé mais ça n'a pas plu non c'est n'y
a pas plus elle n'a pas voulu
recommencer à faire l'amour avec john
crawford et dit-elle l'autre est devenu
malveillantes à son endroit
elle a pris un petit peu en grippe à
cause de ça voilà et lorsqu'on apprend
aussi en lisant votre livre enfin c'est
ce qu'elle a dit en tous les cas dans
ces bandes c'est qu'elle ne connaissait
pas l'orgasme marilyn monroe 1
c'est tout à fait c'est tout à fait
exact
et si c'est assez étonnant devrait-on
croire avec comme n 1 et et c'est là
justement qu'elle a été très
reconnaissante à son psy 4 qu'il a
décoincé sur ce chapitre
marilyn monroe ne connaissez pas
l'orgasme et son psychiatre lui a
expliqué qu'un orgasme ce produit non
pas dans l'est dans les parties
génitales je dirais mais dans la tête
voilà les belles savais pas ça elle
pensait que leur came se situer
vous pensez quoi fabien à vous on les
traduit un besoin d'un traducteur
non sérieusement l'orgasme il est ici
tous leurs gains dans la mêlée
par exemple la douche à des jeux à
travers le jeu ouais
et puis dans la tête aussi je crois ce
qu'a raconté le psychiatre
je crois que c'est armande altaï qui va
nous départager armand moi je crois que
marilyn était tellement gentil elle
voulait tellement faire plaisir elle
était trop préoccupés par le fantasme
qu'elle vous les procurer bah oui je
pense que c'est ça qui est juste allé
jusqu'à lui bloquer tout je pense
qu'elle voulait pas perdre le contrôle
parce qu'elle voulait surtout être aimé
et surtout faire plaisir mais ça ne
répond pas à la question côté rue de
metz qui est extraordinaire c'est qu'aux
états unis il ya plein de bouquins comme
ça de théories sur les complots les
conspirations ils viennent très souvent
des best-sellers et alors les américains
finissent par croire force de lire des
bouquins excusez moi comme le vôtre ils
finissent par croire que saddam hussein
est liée à oussama ben laden que les
femmes hussein possède des armes de
destruction massive
est-ce qui a pas en ce moment comme ça
un dérapage général en amérique sur
toutes ces théories du complot de la
conspiration non maniban disons qu'il ya
eu beaucoup de livres mais pas de
nombreux progrès crédibles c'est à dire
que les gens présentent leurs idées mais
enfin ils sont fondés sur rien du tout
donc
ici c'est un peu différent parce que au
contraire le livre s'appuie quand même
sur des éléments concrets oued baht a
capté avec plaisir lectrices mois fermé
ses portes et milk faut boire du lait
vite bien merci à vous pensez quoi de
cette histoire là je pense est une
théorie comme toutes les autres il va
croiser des dissidents de l'acier pensez
quoi de la théorie de mathew street
je pense que chaque fois qu'on soulève
un coin du voile on est loin de la
réalité mais marilyn ou la plupart des
gens qui se suicident c'est presque
toujours des assassinats très réussi
j'écris une chanson sont arrivés à bon
port
j'ai rêvé de toi en de noir de soeur
marie marie lédé que me dit que marc
levy marley
mathieu merci d'avoir été les plus
grands
mais il n'a pas bu santé
l emporter sur wikio tea for you
c'est une maison bleue adossée à la
colline
on y vient à pied on ne fera peut pas
jeter le lundi au soleil pendant que
nation et son armée à paris le monde y
dégage en anglais
c'est bien
sion
hello bye types ipic j'étais vidé
acheter une théière
merci c'est très sympa merci et
maintenant
voici ses miss la smera
la mouna pouvez pas vous plaindre c'est
à dire ce soir stanislas merhar fabien
galthié franchement peut pas faire
beaucoup mieux à vous regarder tout de
suite sinon une alliance comme si cette
jeunesse tient pas bien tu veux terme et
s il te plait bateau au milieu ça va la
calmer ouais bien 119 cela alors vous a
découvert dans nettoyage à sec excellent
film de anne fontaine où vous semer la
confusion dans un couple propriétaire
d'un pressing avec cette fameuse scène
de sodomie avec charles berling
alors moi j'ai vu le film j'ai adoré le
film je vais adorer
mathilde seigner aussi d'ailleurs a
souvent été formidable ensuite il ya qu
un truc c'est que franchement on voyait
que vous étiez pas des professionnels de
la sodomie avec burning passionnant
honnêtement la province n'était pas dans
l'axé bon c'est pas ça c'est que la
première fois non mais la première fois
ça peut pas se passer aussi facilement
que ça
ah bon 1 tu as plus de sérieux que vous
avez combien de prises pour cette scène
culte 4 way
quand on tourne ça qu'est ce qu'on se
dit après avec berling vous dites quoi
là une fois entre les entre les quatre
entre les prises c'est avant ses dix des
treize jeux c'est considéré comme une
cascade sérieusement sérieusement
j'avais vous fait des plaisanteries
d'enlever des plaisanteries du genre tu
as un beau cul
non je ferai ça moi j'essaierai de
détendre l'atmosphère faisant pas un
beau cul tu sais je peux rentrer dans
une bouteille bien en tous les cas ce
film vous a valu à nice l'as le césar du
meilleur espoir 1998 ensuite il et jean
claude brisseau manuel de oliveira avec
la led chantal akerman avec la captive
benoît jacquot adolphe mais voilà vous
avez été battu par benoît magimel pour
la pianiste deux années que et
aujourd'hui vous revenez à la fiche de
merci docteur ray d'andrew litvak avec
dianne wiest jane birkin bulle ogier et
roschdy zem voilà oui je fasse
l'histoire dans l'histoire c'est bien
vous êtes homo une fois de plus il faut
être plus excusez moi mais vraiment vous
prenez rendez-vous téléphonique avec
avec des hommes et l'un d'eux vous
demande de vous cacher dans le placard
aux états unis ça veut dire être
homosexuel voilà tube in the closet et
on dira claude queen ça veut dire une
reine de placards ou une folle de plaka
aux états unis vous êtes caché dans le
placard a effectivement nous en france à
jo lire des chasseurs convoi plus
rageant culpin vous êtes caché dans le
placard effectivement et vous assister
non pas à une scène d'amour mais un
meurtre par poignard d'âge dans le dos
comme ça voilà est sûre ce après avoir
vu ça vous rentrez chez vous vous
réfugiez auprès de votre mère et vous
apprenez à ce moment là que votre père
n'est pas mort d'homme accident de
voiture mais qu'il a été poignardé dans
le dos dans une chambre d'hôtel donc là
vous allez voir un psychiatre le fameux
docteur ray mais il vient de mourir
c'est incroyable scénario complètement
psychanalytique le psychiatre diane
j'arrêterai après vient de mourir il a
été remplacé par jane birkin et là ça
devient un tourbillon absolument
incroyable film intéressant chose cette
comédie qui changent break différentes
c'est un truc à l'américaine
fait à la française et à la française
fait à l'amérique on voit que c'est un
américain qui a filmé paris espace à
paris et ça ça donne ça donne un truc
étrange aux filles et ça change un petit
peu quoi et on va en profiter pour
regarder à quoi ça ressemble comme ça
comprend par les mains des saints moi je
suis surtout très branché par tous les
trucs qui font mec entre mecs qui font
mec tu vois des trucs très mec mais qui
si vous me parliez de vous j'ai peut
être une solution
allez voir merci
notre invité ce soir bien alors ce qu'il
faut dire quand même un stanislas merhar
c'est qu'avant ce film c'est la première
fois que vous êtes resté aussi longtemps
sans tourner depuis que vous êtes acteur
évidemment vous dites j'ai l'impression
que quelque chose s'est cassé en moi
peut-être ce que je dégage n'est pas
terrible qu'est ce que c'est cette perte
de confiance subite la gipa je suis un
peu le dernier fils michel deville way
un monde presque paisible way le dernier
jour du tournage
michel deville qui est monsieur c'est
bien à l'organisateur dit c'est ton
dernier plan de cinéma depuis ça ce
serait un de films il me dit ça
gentiment il m'a dit c'est ton dernier
plan de cinéma toi tu dis accrue tard et
elle sait qu'elle et moi je vous dire
que non - non mais croire l'âge est une
spécialiste harmonie l'évaluation un
petit coup de mou là il a des yeux
tristes
ouais c'est beau crise non il est
typique typiquement le héros romanesque
vrai il a le regard de jacques dutronc
un peu ça la perfidie elle étonne qu est
ce qu elle est bonne en évaluation même
sens non mais c'est vrai manque de
confiance en vous un petit peu stanislas
en ce moment moi ça vient d'où cette
manque de confiance
ça vient de la musique
donc c'était quoi ton enfance bas il a
fait de la musique du piano piano
beaucoup beaucoup ensuite il a quitté sa
il en a eu ras-le-bol
il y avait de la dorure marans avec tes
parents t'ont quoi tes parents comme
métier a man legends east et va pas
baillif vue il avoue je suis et de
production de cinéma en slovénie et à
l'adolescence et ailleurs en conflit
avec à 16 ans par là pourquoi
une info s'occuper de lui ce garçon là
je place je suis bien placé je pense que
vous êtes très bien placé non mais je
vais vous dites je suis toujours sur le
fil
et finalement quand je joue ça peut
basculer dans le juge comme ça peut
basculer dans le à chier moi j'avais
cette espèce de sans arrêt quoi de doute
très profond c'est pénible parce qu'on a
envie de refaire des sept blessés les
scènes à chaque fois quoi j'ai je me
force à dire non je vais pas demander
aux mecs de refaire 50 prise merci au
point en face à la bombe a fait
interdire leurs feuilles bien sûr
wallers arabi peut être mieux bien sûr
alors vous êtes toujours sur le faisait
toujours sur le fil stanislas merhar et
vous dites ça peut basculer dans le juge
comme ça peut basculer dans le à chier à
chier l aimons bien méchant il a
commencé juste il a fini à chier c'est
très bizarre allez troisième prise le
103e donc c'est nice la smera vous dites
je suis toujours sur le fil finalement
quand je joue ça peut basculer dans dans
le juste comme dans le à chier
ce qui est terrible si vous n'aimez pas
votre image par exemple quand on dit je
vous le dis mouna quand on dit à
stanislas qu'il est un véritable jeune
premier qu'il a un beau ténébreux qui
les romantiques comme vous l'avez il a
du talent mais et ben salem c'est ça
vous aimez pas non mais à cause du piano
voilà la musique a été extrêmement
importante dans sa vie
je préfère et hélène grimaud la whey en
fait je me voyais pas faire un truc
comme ça à la triomphe romain ça vous
ferait du bien un triomphe romain burel
oui pensez que vous ne méritez pas non
elle le mérite et quand j'ai vu
l'émission ya rarement des besoins de
musiciens classiques
ouais et ils ont pas vraiment une place
dans le monde
c'est vrai et elle a pas eu de triomphe
romain et croyant qu'elles le méritent
bravo son album s'appelle credo est
jamais sûr puisqu'on peut traire des
spéciale dédicace moi je pense que
garcimore a fait une carrière magnifique
chinoise a quittés trop tôt et que plus
personne ne parle de lui je vois qu'on
passe à un triomphe romain garcimore
bien par six morts mais ce qu'elles sont
c'est que vous n'aimez pas ce pourquoi
on vous aime
puisque je voulais qu'on donnait des
concerts et ont même pour ça alors
effectivement je dis que vous n'aimez
pas ce pourquoi on vous aime parce que
tout commence avec une certaine céline
rencontré quand vous aviez 11 ans annie
cela c est le dix ans et puis un jour
quand vous avez 18 ans votre père meurt
vous êtes triste et elle vous aime
encore plus et vous dites que votre
malheur est devenu à ce moment là une
forme de séduction
ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui quand on lève
pour son côté triste son côté comme ça à
peu ténébreux salle fait flipper c'est
reviennent la ce se refuse d'être aimé
ça vient du fait d'avoir été aimée au
moment où vous étiez triste ouais je
trouvais grossier de tomber amoureux de
moi parce que j'avais ce malheur ouais
il est donc aujourd'hui toutes les
filles qui vont vous aimez en vous
voyant pas ce que ça va être énorme tout
maintenant parce qu'il ya cinéma il ya
tout de même des petits qui protestent
ils disent qu'on gâche le métier non
mais là on va recevoir des psys là on va
recevoir des larmes à recevoir d'état
gmail de deux filles qui vont être folle
de vous parce qu'elle vous trouve un
petit peu triste et ça vous voulez pas
non si il n'a pas le dire parce que
c'est comme ça qu'ils attrapent mais
c'est un super bon calcul
ces garçons est très très fort avec
césar de cocker edwards est grave il ya
eu ces lignes a eu cécile qui vous a
quitté pendant le tournage du de ville
et vous dites j'ai jamais autant pleuré
et là les filles vous aime encore plus
cher qu'à chaque fois que vous annoncez
que vous êtes malheureux vous comprenez
bien que ça déclenche encore plus
d'amour je les fichiers aussi ouais
c'est dur devrait se poser comme ça si
je ne fais tu veux qu après céline et
cécile ont pas sa colline tu tu veux
qu'on parle un peu dallas est ferait du
bien tu as un dossier bah oui sur la
connaît bien qu ici même je trouve qu'il
est plutôt celle de beaucoup d'humilité
quand tu vois que ça tu crois que c'est
un genre qui se donne toi
non je les ai vus dans les coulisses il
était hyper stressée non je crois que
c'est un bon acteur la presse que tout
le monde dit qu'il clip un peu trop et
voilà un bon c'est pas méchant n'en
faudrait pas qu'ils se foutent en l'air
tout voir et c'est ça oui ça on est
inquiet pour lui ce n'est pas que j'ai
dit je n'ai pas que les 10,6 en lacets
en toile avait voilà là comment ça va là
présentement qu'elle était à présenter
sincèrement tu ne fais hyper bien à
chaque fois mordret la file sur quatre
c'est ça oui c'est michel leeb à la
perfection une chance là l'état présent
votre esprit là comment ça va là ça me
ferait un peu faire de films au monde au
film voulait faire un film
ouais parce que je sais pas si je suis
capable encore je crois que c'est pas un
film tu vas attendre d'autre talent et
qu'on me propose des trucs si ça si ça
n'arrive jamais fait un film si je vais
peut-être avec à tbilissi je vais aller
faire un vrai à ba voila armande
évaluation immédiatement il faudrait
peut-être qu'il joua un rôle de truands
des terreaux et éroder parce qu'il est
il est un premier temps comment est-ce
que c'est des torturés par son engin il
est pas à sa place alors attendez vous
dites qu'il est torturée par son
angélisme
oui enfin moi je suis pas souvent
actrice mais lorsque je jouais fed dans
la journée si je riais je vais arrêter
tous les héros faut pas que je reste ce
soir je vais mourir
et comme il porte un personnage
douloureux il a peur peut-être des
prospects en cause de ça il est bien non
bien alors écoutez pour remonter le
moral de stanislas merhar pour le donner
la pêche
on va lui faire l'interview cire pompes
[Musique]
si ça se fait rare vous êtes sans doute
l'un des meilleurs acteurs de votre
génération le meilleur le meilleur qui
pourrait vous succéder tiens ça le fait
rire et tout ça y est tu vois ça marche
toujours un petit coup d'un petit coup
de polish vous êtes conscient de votre
charisme exceptionnel sign classe g
problème de coiffure
kiala pourtant on fait tout ce qu'on
peut en effet dégradé ce côté alors tout
paris bruisse de vos exploits sexuels
c'est vrai que c'est un super coup et
stanislas du slovène slovène à la luna
validé alors vous êtes très très
généreux il paraît que vous êtes très
tolérant très généreux c'est ça non mais
dites oui valoriser lieu
oui oui rassure moi t'as pas le gaz chez
toi
l'épaisse voûte la tête dans le micro on
il a pas l'air bien savoir si on perd
plus que ça non extrêmement généreux
extrêmement tolérant extrêmement cultivé
cette joie de vivre communicative
c'est quand même quelque chose et
surtout très drôle mais à la base ça a
fait crac mois en commun cette adresse
maintenant et break non on va dire au
revoir mandat pourquoi
non non non je regarde la garde avec
alarme en soit jamais sans déconner tu
fais comme enfants rendez vous pour deux
matches c'est un peu une chanson douce
que ma maman
armande vous partez oh là là là là là
vous quittez laurent tu te fais pas de
comment on appelle ça gérontophilie j'ai
15 ans puisque toi toi on parle un peu
ça se trouve ce sera pas sexuel on
échange des idées on s'en fout des
années armand qui touchent pas ah non
non je ne promets pas de charge déjà dit
ça y est je vois se promener le soir
parce que je ne raccroche pas tu vas t
you gotta pauvreté donc à mon nom cinq
minutes armande on va parler de plein de
trucs sans déconner tu as tendance à
michel leeb bien harmonie vous restez un
petit peu pour faire plaisir à laurent
vraiment quelques minutes de plus
et maintenant
[Musique]
non bien sûr
voici sur vidal man
c'est finalement demain soir mais
mettez-vous au milieu je pense que vous
mettez vos milieu fabien comment ça va
elle était bien à l'extérieur
ouais t'as vu laurent milliat un petit
peu de vocation métier de petits ledit
mouvement des cheveux c'est comme ça on
pourra paulo heureusement j'ai un bon
quoi ça très fort le coiffeur merci et
comment on peut faire ça c'est
incroyable
il faut déjà beaucoup de cheveux bien
vous connaissez tous le monde là un
petit peu armande altaï qu'on ne
présente plus qu'a voulu rester parce
que vous veniez car mentalement nous
laisse en année oui et quand je vais
finalement soffites jouit elle vient il
m'a dit ah les descentes en font a dit
je serais morte car au château mais je
remplis ma vie si vraiment elle m'a dit
il ya sophie thalmann je reste salée
concernant de l'incroyance et war mandin
d'une seule pièce ça me fait plaisir de
voir un monde pour de vrai parce que
j'ai habité dans la petite et vois tu
vois il m'a fait plaisir on vous avait
sonné sa smera sûr sourire qu'on a pris
m
la très beaux yeux à benfica moi je
serais déjà en tant que garçon je trouve
très séduisant je serai une fille et
vous connaissez mon oeil ou non oui
c'est une femme très généreuse très
riche c'est ce soir-là plein dont 2,3
millions de francs à arlette laguiller
et beaucoup d'argent à tout sans
frontières voilà et c'est sur un très
bon place un rabot mougins millions de
francs et l'aiguillé coule sans
frontières je faisais un peu pareil
parfois bien alors comment ça va ok mais
ça va sophie thalmann donc un mètre 80
tels grandissant et manon et ça ça déjà
pour moi c'est prohibitif mais j'ai
mangé beaucoup de shoots assume enfin
qu'une fille soit plus loin à l'horizon
c'est pas possible j'ai à présent avec
un garçon bon comme si ça fait autre
chose donc sophie thalmann longtemps
surnommé la girafe ou la grande godiche
ou babar petit bar à cause des oreilles
décollées comme un boulet sa maman
jamais à plus bas bas n'ont demandé si
je captais mieux que la radio pour
s'inscrire
non je t'en prie c'est pas moi c'est
geneviève alors non ce que dit geneviève
au sujet de ce alors j'ai vu geneviève
hier laurent payet elle te fais un gros
bisou je serai peut-être le déclic de la
réconciliation car elle m'a chargé de te
faire un gros bisou laurent chargé de te
faire un cadeau une boîte de thon compte
pas de ton pour les miss as aix et la
voilà il manie surtout tu lui donnes qui
lui dit que j'ai envie de la revoir tous
ces jeunes vierges et mieux je continue
c'est le passé et qui sait tout ouais
c'est fini c'était des conneries
voilà bon ça va tout va bien maintenant
ça me vient alors à moi le truc bien
alors donc les girafes en tous les cas
ça vous a pas empêché de devenir miss
mieux à 20 ans comme quoi rnis meuse à
20 ans tu te rends compte
elle a progressé de rennes à 21 les miss
france à 22
quelle carrière est la nouvelle miss
cameroun quand même fait 2e pas voulu et
on descend 1997 est donc élue miss
france
avec cette fameuse petite phrase jean
pierre foucault qui vous demandent
voulais faire plus tard et vous ne
répondez prendre notre place et
j'attends tout genre et vous attendez
toujours 15 millions de téléspectateurs
ont été témoins de votre ambition je
dirais même de votre arrivisme d'une
certaine façon mais voilà et vous
attendez toujours foucault est toujours
là ouais ça me suis pas inscrit à oicha
tu l'appelles l'atteignent voilà alors
quand on a été miss france le reste ton
toujours je penserai à vis bahia qui a
croisé les gens dans la rue
sur la france partout c'est toujours
dans il est toujours présent pour la
paix dans le monde toujours non mais
quand on est miss france on est pour la
paix dans le monde pour ça mais c'est
sympa c'était un peu le même discours
pour toutes les miss étaient toujours
dans la misère soit juste quelque part
et que tu marques des animaux comme
arlette et que tuer des animaux pour
faire des manteaux c'est dégueulasse ça
c'est vrai il est mignonne mais je me
moque de tout sauf de ce en quoi ils
croient non pas bientôt terry je parle
jamais la vraie fourrure à y porter
jamais de vrais faux en tentant laurent
lessard train d'avouer qu'elle ne porte
jamais sa vraie fourrure
vous continuez à sourire toute la
journée depuis que j'ai depuis miss
france est la preuve
mais on apprend sourire c'est vrai c'est
même le soleil va se font bien non c'est
vrai est ce que vous mettez toujours des
des talons avec des maillots de bain oui
toujours après une fois qu'on est aimé
ce pansement génie ouais non mais t'es
pas de talent marche souvent qu'il n'y
en crise moi ouais quand on vous offre
des fleurs vous les rendez au public
systématiquement nancy car pour moi vous
les gardez vous bien alors on tue les
cas madame de fontenay que nous aimons
beaucoup 9e
geneviève notre ami jeunes a dit il y
aura un avant et un après sophie
thalmann voilà c'était avant oui si
avant le bouquin soyez prêts si bien
dire parce qu'effectivement pour l avant
et après ces coups thalmann puisque vous
avez publié l'envers du diadème chez
notre ami michel lafon tirage en plein
de rires ouais moi je veux juste faire
la liste un jour là déjà parlé dans ce
que bah vous plaignez des fêtes locales
des foires gastronomiques des dédicaces
photos des mains au cul dr jacques
faciale
c'était dans le rapport j'avais vu un
jeune aventurier miss france
donc mon nom n'y a pas que ça les mains
au cul la radinerie de geneviève de
fontenay qui vous aura de loire d'as en
fit un jour vous vous êtes vous invite à
manger la fameuse boîte de toi avec les
biscottes pas ces règles
7 g de terrible s'est déjà dit nigel
farmer en plus une bête de temps donc
ensuite après les miss france en 99 vous
avez présenté téléfoot vous en souvenez
est ce que vous savez ce que c'est un
petit pont par un petit bout ouais bah
oui c'est quand on passe la balle entre
les jambes du football allemand vient
d'annoncer un grand pont alors quand on
passe la balle en dessous d'un grand fou
voilà vous savez ce que c'est la trique
le truc c'est ce que s'est passé un truc
qui est très dur et faire je sais pas
l'expliquer ouais t'as canal+ même nom
c'est pas le coup du chapeau 4 et 6 mais
c'est super dur à faire sur expérience
et candidat potentiel mais pas c'est
super dur et je sais ce que c'est toi
c'est marqué trois fois mais ça peut
être un basket hand be en football
thierry henry est très forts pour ça
une aile de pigeon c'est ce que c'est
juste que c'est une aile de pigeon a été
hâtée des prix combien il ya de carton
jaune avant une expulsion
combien ce carton jaune à van nhon
carton rouge avant l'expression combien
faut-il de carton jaune avant d'être
expulsé de cette dure non c'est pas été
à téléfoot
et justement j'étais pas là pour parler
de ça actuellement chacun s'arrange
usées travail et n'y a pas photo à
combien ça coûte
aujourd'hui vous avez quitté tf1 non
c'est juste qu'ils n'ont pas proposé une
émission dans laquelle je me sentais
bien effectivement alors on vous
retrouve sur paris première vous
commenterez le 6 décembre 2003
l'élection de miss monde
oui en chine 50 moi je reste ici
l'élection et nous on sera ici à paris
je commenterai avec christophe roux il
aura une rediffusion le lendemain dans
l'après midi à 14h30
on est aussi sur rtl et on fait cela on
a vu ce soir à quel point vous garez
témoin l'a fait encore plus écouter la
radio ou pas loi et vous faites aussi
des commentaires d'équitation oui je
commence dimanche prochain sur sport +
demain
franchement qu'est ce que vous
connaissez au cheval belge et j'ai
personnellement un cheval s'appelle
auteuil et alors je lui murmure tous les
jours à l'oreille rhume
c'est un cheval et un cheval un peu
commenté
or on me disait très justement comment
je vais aux champignons et je vais pas
aux truffes 1 2 par la bien vous êtes
prête j'ai qu'un grand mère de christian
vadim s'appelait ardilouze et benoît
haute de verdun entendu ça la semaine
dernière dans l'émission et il m'a
envoyé un mail avec une idée
d'interviews qui s'appelle l'ardilouse
bon l'ardilouse c'est que les trucs de
loose votre pire passage télé à part
suis là ce soir c'était le dernier très
bien votre pire cuite jamais oh non j'ai
une phobie
du vomi donc jamais je ne bois pas être
mal assez bien ça fait bizarre c'est une
chance benjamin est ouest et quand la
champagne ce soir bien et vous je vous
demande pas c'était la veille de la demi
finale
vous avez vu le résultat rien a vu le
résultat à bien votre pire mais avec
sophie schirmeck un bateau de ouais bah
ce serait ça oui c'est xavier de
fontenay dans ce serait qui a le pire de
tout ça serait ce lié avec qu on
apprendrait que
qu'il a déjà quelqu'un vous est arrivé
ça déjà qui t'a fait cela c'est un mec
de la télé ça on arrête arrête
non mais s'ils passent leur hausse à
mèze un mec de la télé
non mais très connu je peux pire
souvenir pierre devons terminer comme ça
dans lequel le l'hôtel campanile est
confortée non non non un truc
bon c'est pas vraiment pire mais elle
l'événement on se demande qu'est ce
qu'il fait là quoi c'était comme un
salon se pacsant dans l'agriculture mais
une fois le storm qui la lie au second
que des toute sa vie non mais on était
dans la boue il faisait super froid et
au milieu des vaches c'est sa
progression avant donner votre pire
expérience homosexuelle
rien n'a pas donc ça te réussit non non
mais je peux en a pas et donc ça veut
dire votre pire moment avec geneviève de
fontenay bassesse était en fait on
n'était pas ensemble mais c'est ce qui
s'est passé par après la sortie du livre
tout ce qui a été dit est un moment
assez dur à vivre
le moment le plus moyen de toute ta
carrière maintenant
[Musique]
je
m
armand jeudi bonne nouvelle est vraie
armande a décidé de rester jusqu'à
maintenant parce que maintenant on a une
chanteuse un peu comme elle donc ça va
c'est pas doublonner
les gars
on m'apporte un coussin pourquoi parce
que j'ai l'air ridicule
ouais je suis un peu oui c'est vrai we
bought 1 ou 2 même la province je m'en
fous c'est pourquoi est ridicule c'est
pas pour regarder
oui après médine je crois pas à ça donne
confiance
tu vois ça disent las il suffit de rien
tu baises et maintenant
[Musique]
voici ci ni la peur
simulateur bonsoir
bonsoir ben les français me ripert très
mal très mal
vient alors la meilleure façon de
présenter cindy lauper c'est ça
[Musique]
maintenant
m
o o
du monde
bien remplie
[Musique]
k
sia
ainsi au camp
encore
à tort
temps
oh
[Musique]
on ira
finie la peur voilà ça c'était ça
c'était la carte de visite
alors
après tout ça vous revenez aujourd'hui
cindy avec un album intitulé atlas qui
est une reprise de deux grands standards
très bien orchestré et très bien chanté
didier drogba
[Musique]
je
obama
pas
[Applaudissements]
google
when you say goodbye
encore
ceux ci
mpk
ça
mais qu'est ce qu'ils font
[Musique]
le triste mais personne ne m'a l'air mal
aux bêtises aux vins
ma place
mal on l'était pas en vain
[Musique]
un livescore
ouais
[Musique]
et
son nouvel album s'appelle michael
oui
tu es
bravo s'y trompe pas vingt-cinq message
pour dire que c'est beau un disque on
passe à la bonne vitesse
comme quoi les gens ne s'y trompe pas ce
que c'est c'est bien moi c'est pas celle
c'est bon alors 10 avait déclaré vous
avez déclaré
si ni la peur je voulais simplement
faire la musique que j'entendais pendant
mon enfance dans mon quartier voilà
effectivement c'est assez réussi je dois
dire dans votre quartier
c'était le queens à new york où vous
avez une enfance un petit peu difficile
avec une mère divorcée des grands
parents maternels immigrants dit cali et
visites ils ont trimé toute leur vie ses
grands parents comme des malades pour
que leur fils soit digne de vrais beaux
américain est en fait ils y sont jamais
arrivés vous dites au rêve américain
c'était juste une illusion pour eux
ensuite en france dans des écoles
catholiques
vous avez été brimés par apport des
bonnes soeurs dont vous dites qu'elle
était rongé de frustration et qu'elle
était extrêmement perverses avec vous
j'ai balayé c'est vrai mais j'ai réussi
à me faire virer donc finalement il ya
un dieu ouais vous vous dites que les
bonnes soeurs vous aviez l'impression
qu'on vous étiez leurs élèves qu'elle
avait été formé par les nazis tellement
elle était dure
oui
le sol de votre seul plaisir à l'époque
c'était là c'était la chorale vous dit
quand je chantais avec la chorale
j'étais un ange et je chantais pour dieu
c'était le seul moment finalement vous
aviez un petit peu de bonheur
je dirais que ça va ça va alors là ça
commence à 9 envoûté nier les cheveux en
vert pour la pour la saint-patrick ses
premières tarif est oui oui c'était pour
cette fête
peu importe bien faire la fête à 10 ans
vous découvrez le rock avec les beatles
à 12 ans en première guitare et là vous
commencez effectivement durant votre
adolescence à avoir les cheveux
multicolores des fringues absolument
excentrique et vous devenez un petit peu
là la dengue du quartier on peut dire
cindy lauper serré quand vous arriviez à
l'école les gens vous jeter des pierres
ça c'est quand je rentrais de
l'université il me lançaient des pierres
effectivement mais vous savez moi
j'aimais bien ses habits vintage mais
c'était pas très à la mode à ce moment
là et puis finalement quand on me
lançait la première paire pierre et bien
je répondais donc c'était c'est un petit
peu de ma faute et alors la maison c'est
très dur vous parlez de votre beau père
en le comparant à freddy vous dit quand
il était là on savait jamais s'il
fallait rire nous font c'est s'enfermer
dans la chambre ah ouais ouais mais ce
que je voulais dire par là c'est qu'en
fait il était une combinaison entre
c'est ce que je voulais dire par là il
est entre les deux freddy ça pourrait
être n'importe qui à l'époque vous
touchez un petit peu la drogue au moment
de l'adolescence un jeu les régions je
suis traité si vous
avant de commencer à chanter et je crois
que chacun près un moment ou un autre
mais bien une question ici j'ai entendu
stanislas rires non je te jure j'ai
entendu sur les réseaux moment précis où
tu as dit le mot drogue
il ya peut-être une piste
je suis atterré herstal je pense comme
ça non je tombais la drogue
cela dit oui c'est stanislas tanner
oliver s'est toujours dit cela c'est
bien sûr alors la saison cyndi lauper
vous quittez le quartier du queens avec
votre chien sparkle et vous fuyez quoi
je rêvais de pouvoir chanter
et puis j'ai réussi à le faire et voilà
et donc ces dix ans plus tard que vous
sortez votre premier album solo she's
the usual 4,5 millions d'exemplaires
vendus seulement aux usa
vous devenez une énorme star
immédiatement d'accord alors c'est vrai
qu'à l'époque vous étiez quand même une
bad girl
aujourd'hui vous reprenez des standards
gs1 qui a dit ça c'est pas vraiment dans
quelle époque c'est vrai que j'étais une
bad girl aujourd'hui vous êtes plus cool
quoi vous chantez des grands standards
de la chanson américaine
alors pour vous rappeler l'époque vous
étiez une bad girl
cindy lauper a offert une interview
batgirl
[Musique]
cindy lauper de batgirl interview à quel
âge avez vous fumez votre premier joint
ainsi mme dié fois tu m'énerves je
dirais que 14 ans et demi si vous avez
vu combien de petits copains dans votre
vie tina loyalistes et avec lesquels je
suis resté sérieux n'est sérieux bon
j'avais 15 ans
sérieux compte et me menace en toi ni au
tour de vis j'aurais adoré faire ça à
doser dans un western manipule aisément
et non j'aurais aimé faire ça mais je
peux donc vous avez eu 20 petit copain
sérieux et si on compte tous il faut
ajouter à 0 forti moi ça va non c'est
beaucoup 40 il vraiment vous combien pas
des copains et des copines c'est pas
énorme 40 alors comme my wife sine die
combien de petits copains en même temps
votre record on va dire 3 combien de
petites copines arménie girlfriend
ouais j'ai essayé ma soeur
on était lesbienne dans cette voie quand
elle avait 20 ans mais pas moi ce
n'était pas moi cynique et la pire
couleur que vous ayez eu pour vos
cheveux et inédit - 91 je voulais
atteindre mes cheveux afin que
véritablement on y voit jaune à l'image
mais malheureusement pour moi ça s'est
très mal terminée et je dirais que ça
que lacoursière couleurs que joe lando
peu verdâtre ça ne colorent hollande au
nom non cette couleur est pas mal a
déclaré je porte toujours très bien
cindy le plus longtemps que vous êtes
resté sans vous l'avez faire du camping
nhs a duré deux semaines
mais je me lavais dans un espèce de
naissance de petite bassine avec le
recul est la réponse que la drogue est
plus dur que vous ayez essayé à part le
succès world war in asie savez lorsque
j'étais petit est normalement quartier
on ne disait que la cocaïne ce n'était
pas très grave on devait pas dépendants
comparativement à l'héroïne alors une
zen la cocaïne certains sont devenus
dépendants mais moi je faisais d'autres
choses ont changé hier m'en sortir je
comprends le français oui après denner
restaurant reste allant après effet dîné
no23 moins d'une heure est au niveau
maximum de saveur
[Musique]
si nos vacances
ça ne rime pas même l'appareil photo n'y
crois pas c'est bien deux doigts de
conclure et ça marche pas c'est pas de
pot cela bon donc cindy merci d'avoir
été avec nous thank you very much
et j accueille maintenant richard
labévière
[Musique]
salut à ma fille qui me dit il s'appelle
richard labbé pierre richard labévière
articule à la déconne bien fait ça va
très bien vous allez bien là bien donc
pardon stan on va changer tu vas prendre
ma place tu vas dire des vannes
qu'est-ce qui se passe il va dire des
vannes et moi je vais faire la tronche
d'accord dans le boeuf fituf et
stanislas les vrais hommes c'est lui la
loupe pour hitler staline en même temps
je vais te faire l' inverse suis pas
bien et toi donc san tu fais des bacs
d'accord donc richard labévière et
rédacteur en chef et éditorialiste à
radio france internationale rfi
avant d'aller plus loin je voudrais
qu'on ait une pensée pour un journaliste
de rfi qui a été assassiné abidjan y ait
autant jean hélène alors donc
parallèlement à votre à rfi vous publier
régulièrement des livres et notamment
chez grasset en 1999 un livre qui
s'appelait dollars de la terreur est
aujourd'hui toujours chez grasset ou
publier les coulisses de la terreur qui
est un petit peu le prolongement du
précédent
car pour vous le 11 septembre 2001 n'est
pas un point de rupture mais en fait une
continuation d'un processus anciens de
rupture voilà alors le pitch de votre
livre est assez simple al qaïda n'existe
pas voilà c'est la phrase finalement la
plus la plus remarquable de votre
bouquin vous dit pour justifier ses
objectifs c'est à dire le pétrole la
guerre sans fin a décrété par les
américains avaient besoin d'al qaïda
superbe invention médiatique pour vous
en fait al qaïda au delà de ce qui s'est
réellement passé
c'est un petit peu une création des
américains si vous voulez avant les
attentats du 11 septembre on n'a jamais
parlé d' al-qaïda alors que les
activistes salif sy salafistes le no2 du
de cette idéologie à la convergence des
frères musulmans et des wahhabites
saoudiens égorger des gens depuis dix
ans en algérie en egypte
on est en zone asie du sud est il faut
rappelons que le premier attentat contre
le world trade center c'est en 93
donc je veux dire les services
américains étaient parfaitement au
courant de qui étaient ces réseaux qui
les ont instrumentalisé est beaucoup
utilisé dans la guerre contre les
soviétiques en afghanistan
si vous voulez jouer ce que vous dites
c'est évidemment tout ça existait déjà
et qu'en fait les américains après le 11
septembre on connaît ce label cette
étiquette al qaïda sur sur ses réseaux
pour permettre en fait aux usa de
justifier un énorme déploiement
militaire et imposer leur vision du
monde
au reste de la planète en si vous voulez
le basculement s'est vraiment octobre
2002 les attentats de bali en novembre
2002 les attentats de mombasa et enfin
mai 2003 attentats de casablanca de
riyad avec les derniers attendaient
d'istanbul et là je veux dire al qaïda
et ben laden absolument rien à voir dans
ces attentats
c'est un peu un terrorisme local en deux
chaînes qui sont arrachés dans des
conditions économiques et politiques et
qui locales et donc qu'ils utilisent
al-qaïda comme un un label une référence
qui ne renvoie pas à une organisation
planet earth que oui ils veulent assez à
souhait c'est que al qaida et c'est tout
l'intérêt de votre livre richard whitt
hugues al-qaïda n'est pas structurée sur
un mode pyramidal internationale comme
l'a été à l'époque le komintern
c'est-à-dire l'internationale communiste
mais en fait ce sont de petits groupes
autonome et que le terrorisme dit tout
s'est délocalisé ses quelque chose vous
l'avez dit
qui a servi à l'armée américaine qui a
facilité le plus grand redéploiement de
moyens militaires ou stratégiques
américains depuis la wilaya moyens et ça
je veux dire il ya dans la mesure où les
américains continuent à nous dire ben
laden est partout il faut mettre cela
américains partout pourquoi tout
simplement pour de l'influent
stratégique aux militaires et des
intérêts économiques
c'est un alibi c'est un alibi solide
alors vite désormais nous vivons dans un
monde orwelliens non qu'orwell 1984 le
monde de la falsification médiatique de
masse la guerre sans fin contre le
terrorisme finalement c'est une
référence flou qui permet en fait
n'importe quelle aventure militaire
l'empiré américain depuis la fin de la
guerre froide et privés des demis c'est
terrible pour un empire
donc il faut bien sans réinventer un
autre l'idéologie de la guerre sans fin
si vous voulez remplace l'idéologie la
guerre froide est ce qui permet un
empire américain de se reconfigurer de
se redéployer de remettre des basses et
des soldats américains partout dans le
monde pour continuer justement à avoir à
continuer à avoir un ennemi et à faire
ce que dit monsieur bush et ses amis néo
conservateurs à poursuivre une guerre
sans fin contre le terrorisme la terreur
alors qu'en fait dites-vous le seul vrai
objectif c'est le le pétrole de l'asie
centrale ce que vous nommez le grand jeu
le nouveau grand jeu
c'est un des objectifs c'est pas le seul
c'est une des raisons de la meilleure
preuve dit vous c'est que quand les
américains sont rentrés dans bagdad
ils ont laissé piller le musée de bagdad
où il y avait des richesses
archéologiques des débuts d'humanité de
notre histoire est en fait le seul
endroit qui a été réellement protégés
c'est le mystère sur la production
pétrolière voilà alors cette cette mamie
américaine sur le pétrole irakien
dites-vous leur assurant fait une mamie
sur l'opep puisque maintenant il pèse au
sein de l'opep ce n'était pas le cas
avant si vous voulez - sur les réserves
pétrolières que sur le contrôle des
cours du brut
or justement les usa depuis qu'ils
occupent l'irak sont moins tributaire
évidemment du pétrole d'arabie saoudite
et vous revenez sur les liens entre les
usa et l'arabie saoudite
les compromissions financière au plus
haut niveau et vous dit qu'un jour ça
risque d'éclater et vous parlez d'un ben
laden gay c'est vrai que le bin laden y
est aujourd'hui quand on travaille sur
ces réseaux et sur leur financement
parce que moi j'ai commencé à travailler
il ya douze ont sur les structures
financières parce que j'étais installé à
genève je voyais passer les valises de
billets si vous voulez eh bien nous
ramène non pas à des banques forcément
ce malienne ou pakistanaises mais a de
l'argent saoudien enchevêtrés en
partenariat avec de l'argent américain
et nous ramène aux grandes sociétés
américaines du complexe militaro
industriel comme bechtel halliburton new
carlisle ces sociétés qui actuellement
sont en charge de la reconstruction de
l'irak et au conseil d'administration de
la plupart de ces sociétés vous
retrouver non seulement le gotha du
parti républicain est d'aider des
idéologues néoconservateurs de
l'administration bush mais vous
retrouvez boukebouche père notamment
excel de carlyle et d'anciens chefs de
la cia comme carlucci à l'aube et le bim
danone gates et ça c'est que si vous
enquêtez très sérieusement sur le
financement du terrorisme
aujourd'hui vous revenez fatalement aux
états unis aux places offshore aux îles
anglo-normandes aux bahamas aux îles
caïmans à curaçao
c'est à dire un fonctionnement de
finances internationales dont au
personne surtout pas les américains
n'ont intérêt à lever le secret ou
l'opacité si vous alors ben laden à vous
confirmer une information qui avait été
donnée par le figaro et puisqu'elle est
pas été démentie maintenant les gens
n'avaient pas beaucoup donné suite
vous confirmez donc cette information
sans laquelle ben laden aurait séjourné
à l'hôpital américain de dubaï en
juillet
2001 donc deux mois avant le wall trade
center et il avait rencontré à ce moment
là un patron de la cia locale en l'idée
c'était finalement assez assez clair
c'était de dire à ben laden écouter on
vous donne la vie sauve vous vous
installez vous voulez à condition que
vous arrêtez finalement vos actions donc
ça veut dire que deux mois avant le wall
trade center vous le vous le confirmer
dans votre bouquin les américains ont
proposé un marché à ben laden tout à
fait vous avez raison de rappeler que
cette information était sorti en fin
novembre 2001 way dans le figaro et sur
les ondes de rfi
à l'époque on avait le factuel avec tout
ça a été confirmé aux meilleures sources
y compris par des services secrets
arabes de la région donc on était
parfaitement sûre du factuel
on a fait pas le sens et la lecture de
ce séjour et de cette rencontre avec le
résident local de la cia dubaï qui
s'appelle larry mitchell
on a on a relancé l'umq est on a refait
une enquête de proximité à dubaï avec ma
collègue allaient alexandra richards on
pendant de nombreuses semaines
et effectivement on a pu recouper avec
des témoignages de personnes travaillant
pour l'administration de l'hôpital
américain qui effectivement larry
mitchell le résident de local d'acier à
dubaï avait rencontré ben laden à
l'hôpital américain le 12 juillet 2001
pour essayer si vous voulez de déboucher
sur un accord sur une ultime négociation
pour que les afghans arabe de la
mouvance ben laden dans le monde cessent
de s'en prendre à des intérêts
américains
donc ça ne s'est pas fait contre son
retour en arrière dit je vous rappelle
que ben laden avait été privé de sa
nationalité saoudienne
en 94 si al qaïda était une structure
pyramidale comme le komintern liaisons
internationales
on pourrait discuter avec un chef mais
on pourrait faire un deal ce que vous
êtes en train de nous expliquer là ce
soir c'est que finalement il ya
tellement de base d'al-qaïda dans le
monde ya tellement d'endroits où ou ce
label est revendiquée qu'on veut pas
négocier en fait et ce qui est très
étrange c'est que depuis le 11 septembre
marqué dans la presse à pau du 11
septembre au printemps 2002 toutes les
semaines on arrêtait un cerveau d'al
qaïda
senna lui arrêté qu'un cerveau on a du
bon donc ça inquiétant weeps le couvent
allons vivre à lucie être cerveau - c
d'accord quand on négocier avec l'ira ou
avec les farc selon hélène que l'on
vienne bon il ya une structure des
questions à poser à notre amie sophie
non enfin moi j'aimerais bien savoir
comment ça va se terminer mais bon
personne prête mal richard labévière
léger la terreur merci
[Musique]
m
j'accueille maintenant bruno salomone
alors bruno salomone bonsoir tu arrive
juste après al qaïda ouais c'est comme
les armes et des munitions ont été assez
flipper bien ce temps je suis super
content tu es content de ça m'émeut
savez moustiques alors bon soir on s'est
connus avec ça
ça donne un peu le frisson cet été
c'était début quand tu entends des sas
graines de stars tu disais ça il faut
que j'y aille à l'époque c'est le sketch
de la caissière la caissière la première
c'est comment je la connais ci a fait un
petit peu comme ça c'est comme ça que je
faisais des sketches quoi tu vois je
suis là que vous avez un truc jean bip
quoi tu vois assez oui c'est ça
[Musique]
et maintenant à sa manière
ta mère tu sais qu est ce qu elle m'a
dit quand même alors ça ça ça c'est la
cerise sur le mât doute ça c'est la
boulette qui fait déborder le vase
un m'a dit qu'elle avait trouvés sous
ton sommeil bien à l'abri des regards
indiscrets
un disque de comédie musicale roméo et
juliette et roméo et juliette
mettez dalpé ou quoi
c'est quoi cette musique de barbares
y'a même pas
quand je pense que tu as été bercée au
scratch
ça me fait mal à la route
je dire moi je me bats contre toutes les
injustices de l'homme et de la terre
parce que moi j'estime canton comme
humain l'homme doit et par conséquent la
femme se doit
ces bâtards être les égos qu'identique
egalitarian est il de celle non excusez
moi mais quand j'entends encore par des
unes de ses créations raciale
au 21ème siècle à lyon de l'amp et
filles
c'est pas un peu rétro me donne de l'air
c'est évident je dire on est pareils on
est tous pareil alors acceptons nos
différences
comme je défais boulet mélange regard
des milkshakes me vient un moment où ce
qu'on a tous regardé ventre du nombril
et qu'on bouge le hic
voilà bruno c'est à l'homme
au bataclan bien
ça ça va de compte et derrière ça y est
c'est vrai ça y est ali moi alors malgré
malgré l'importance que j'ai eues dans
ta carrière carrément insatiable ah ben
moi j'ai vécu des 5 sata
ça doit pas empêcher de me trahir quand
même le très bas tu vas voir qu'est ce
que je fais bonjour on va au bristol
je vais un téléphone portable s'il vous
plaît
[Musique]
ça je suis quelque chose pourquoi je
suis désolé un schéma attendait marc
messins ont taxé
axa lâchait fin juillet
ah bon mais c'est gentil qui m'est
arrivé j'ai eu
- 19 moi je suis content ce que je sais
et vous
donc tu avais vous je suis content vous
ça vous soumets moi je ne sais pas vous
qui me saoule et c'est le fait qu'il ya
vingt-six personnes qui m'attendait que
je vois pas quelle heure on va arriver
comme ça
ouais
26 personnes défaits à tous
à
soirée
faites des touffes peut tout me range
aux chandelles de temps en temps mais je
tousse s'habitue aux chandelles aux
chandelles sa gt 41 g/t au carnet je
réalise vraiment
chaque année h 30 mon oreille est en
fête tf1 reculé
c'est une fois ça m'a fait mal je vais
pas recommencer
continuez continuez stéphane stéphane
thiery sylvie rejoint ses plus loin
thierry pierre clément way
dès le 6 janvier 1940 1 c'est plus loin
steph ses fans vous étiez au collège
saint michel a dit ouais à la faculté de
lettres de montpellier fils de victoires
10 sont sains et de madame juliette rené
gastinel je pouvais pas oublier tout
cela
samedi dernier corti s'est déguisé il
s'est déguisé en enfant thomass a tu
t'es fait [__] thierry bienvenue à
taxi sur m6 à laval
bon port
bongo ondimba
bruno salomone
formidable a chanté sortait de chez
canal+
je suis en gardant les accies comme par
hasard mon portable il avait retiré la
puge peu plus téléphoner jeté avec toi
ça a duré 40 minutes et pendant 40
minutes j'ai cru que tu étais un vrai
chauffeur de taxi fan de moi tu vois
alors matière maintenant une interview
si j'étais
[Musique]
anomone si j'étais un bruit un bruit
ouais
parlant de ça ouais même pas les gens
qui pleuraient des dents donc j'aimerais
bien être que j'aime paraîtra si j'étais
un animal un animal je pense que je
serai un hybride genre le faucon taupe
par exemple ouais
l'animal qui vole le plus vite et qui
voit rien un meuble une secrétaire aux
légumes d'origine est qu un saint saint
saint maclou tâche déchire une bonne
pour base une mauvaise imitation une
mauvaise imitation
je sais faire le bruit de la chaussette
quand on enlève des pieds par est sûre
ça fait cela c'est pas mal ça une bonne
imitation d'une bonne je sais faire tu
sais avec la voix de joe dassin
vas-y tout seul
alors serge on va le refaire et tuant
bellegarde et vas-y fais-le phase calme
comme sa puce
et bien alors un motif d'embauché blanc
brouille qu'on me pose trop de questions
ouais ouais un homme politique bernard
menez
ouais c'est présent une odeur une odeur
la pyramide du louvre pas ça semble
bizarre une infirmité laurent baffie ni
et maintenant place au blind test
ce soir ça caille aux platines stéphane
pompougnac bouniagues bon soir donc vous
connaissez le principe du blind test
mouna tu connais le principe
fabien faut expliquer il s'agit pas
d'être quatrième le le blind test elle
c'est très simple je veux l'interprète
voilà c'est tout un d'accord
l'interprète stanislavski ses clips ou
pas il ya des équipes au départ c'est
par équipes il ya l'équipe de stanislas
merhar contre l'équipe de mouna ayoub
voilà et après c'est chacun pour sa
gueule quand on arrive aux banques aux
oméga bon coup et cetera de tous les
pays quoi je vois l'international vrai
ça peut être champion la peau n'est ce
pas monsieur je ne sais pas s'il fera
attention premier morceau up
broadway
oui
les lorrains
non
oh
je n'ai que ça va
mais si
ce rôle est donc toi tu es donc je vois
ça si méline évidemment comme il a
écouté le soufflage
mais sa mère faisait maintenant stéphane
numéro 2
[Musique]
il aa
m
un numéro 3 stéphane
oui
alors nous
je rame
qu'est ce que tu as je suis ailleurs tu
dit jo privat
c'est l'esprit je sais je suis là c'est
que ces tiroirs du bas et pour que
l'espoir de voir des os cassés mal
rangée tu fous rien tu es chez toi toute
la semaine rien lâcher chez moi dans ma
tête eût déjà la maison le branleur rien
chez soi toute la semaine
non
bonjour
nous
est ce que j'ai la place de stan je sais
ce que j'ai eu des petits mois ça fait
deux points pour eux et un point pour
eux seulement
c'est marrant ça j'aurais cru que
j'étais devant un bon attention ce temps
là on va changer stephen
dans la demeure
ouais je pense que fabien galthié
la banlieue
petit riff et
[Musique]
voilà pas
dans les moeurs non
m
fabien galthié fabien galthié tu vois
comme quoi t'as pas tout perdu
finalement fait bien attention stéphane
cet achat de thomson non non
6 échappe t il à chaud
[Musique]
et
donc j'en ai un 3-3 méline effectivement
on est à 3 3 et maintenant attention
stefan wey
bravo
alors
j'étudie un truc tu as bien quand il les
trouve c'est la première note à séparer
ses skis sont pris à rigole pas nui à la
première note
mais
oui
attention stéphane
ce
et
il a dit tout à l'heure en soto qui l'a
d'ailleurs
alors 4,4 aulas si chaud là olalala le
par équipes à se départager sur le
chanteur qui arrive maintenant puisqu'on
en est à 4 4 le par équipes est très
très chaud attention stéphane genou le
soufflement
j'adore
[Musique]
je
m
1 80
c'est joe jackson way
donc on est à 4 4 à la fin du par équipe
maintenant si chacun pour sa gueule on
va commencer avec le banco très très
difficile ce soir
attention stéphane france gall un groupe
européen
le ton monte
à
[Musique]
merci des bailleurs
ça casse
[Applaudissements]
odyssée ghrib a tenu hier qui chantent
au dc comics à ces drames x10 et ça
c'est de là qu'il a écrit je leur ai
laissé le mec qui a écrit pratiquement
tous les tubes de la tamla motown et il
s'appelle vous ne savez pas là mon désir
et oui regardez bien ce jeudi ses
marques et aux longues heures non ils
ont écrit tous les tubes des suprêmes
tous les tubes des forums etc
on continue stéphane j
[Musique]
et 5
ça
[Musique]
oui donc jusqu'à présent ces longs ma
fille est maintenant donc il reste un
morceau c'est le méga bon qu le morceau
par morceau qui n'entend super moins
bien ici en plus de critiquer les mas
dieu que je connais très mal dit celui
qui va trouver celui-là aura tout gagné
sinon c'est laurent qui aura tout gagné
attention maintenant côté fan
[Musique]
les stranglers way tard et comment tu
t'appelles
je manque un labrador merci c'est franck
legros gagnant bravo
pour le dr
[Musique]
merci monsieur pompougnac c'était tout
le monde en parle avec lui
besancenot mouna ayoub soutient
l'association
à l'occasion de la journée mondiale
contre le sida le 1er décembre
fabien galthié calendrier 2004 dieux du
stade au profit de l'association
deux tomes dvd making of du calendrier
escale à money time c'était
vient de loin chez jean claude lattès
matthew smith victime chez plon
stanislas merhar merci docteur ray de
rendre au lido avec stanislas merhar
tyan lichtenberg
j'ai d'ailleurs le 3 décembre sophie
thalmann commentera élections des miss
monde 2003 le 6 décembre sur paris
première à 20h15 la rivière les
coulisses de la terreur s'était invité
chez grasset cindy lauper son album
s'appelle at last
bruno salomone une seule aumôneries de
dean au bataclan du 11 décembre 10
janvier 2004 vient chercher dès midi là
bruno salomone au bataclan miami mais
l'étoile à stéphane pompougnac merci
l'album s'appelle les bigoudens merci
beaucoup
reporters sans frontières l'album de
youtube pour la liberté de la presse au
prix de 8 au profit des journalistes
emprisonnés dans le monde
rendez vous fera la semaine prochaine ya
lequel est en mai dans quinze jours
[Musique]
oh
mais chut
g
[Musique]
suite
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu